i believe our official scientific world
view is incompatible with the reality of
consciousness do you think we're living
in a simulation we could be in the
matrix this could be a very vivid dream
there's going to be a few people that
are now visualizing a pink elephant a
hamster has consciousness except for
cats who are evil automatons that are
void of consciousness consciousness is
the basis of moral value moral concern
do you think there will be a time in
like 20 30 50 years when we're not
morally okay turning off the power to a
robot
the following is a conversation with
philip gough philosopher specializing in
the philosophy of mind and consciousness
he is a pan psychist which means he
believes that consciousness is a
fundamental and ubiquitous feature of
physical reality of all matter in the
universe he is the author of galileo's
error foundations for a new science of
consciousness and is the host of an
excellent podcast called mind chat
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now here's my
conversation with philip gough
i opened my second podcast conversation
with elon musk
with a
question about consciousness and pan
psychism the question was
quote does consciousness permeate all
matter i don't know why i opened the
conversation this way he looked at me
like what the hell is this guy talking
about
so he said no because we wouldn't be
able to tell if it did or not so it's
outside the realm of the scientific
method do you agree or disagree with
elon musk's answer
i disagree i guess i i guess i do think
consciousness pervades matter in fact i
think consciousness is the ultimate
nature
of matter
so
as for whether it's outside
of the scientific method
i think there's
a fundamental challenge at the heart of
the science of consciousness that we
need to face up to which is that
consciousness is is not publicly
observable
all right i can't look inside your head
and see your feelings and experiences
we know about consciousness not you know
not from doing experiments or public
observation
we just know about it from our immediate
awareness of our feelings and
experiences
so it's qualitative not quantitative as
you talk about yeah that's another
aspect of it so there are a couple of
reasons consciousness
i think is not susceptible to the
standard or not fully susceptible to the
standard scientific approach one reason
you've just raised is that it's
qualitative rather than quantitative
another reason is it's not publicly
observable so i mean science science is
used to dealing with
uh unobservables right you know
fundamental particles quantum wave
functions other universes none of these
things are
observable
but there's an important difference
with all these things
we postulate unobservables
in order to explain what we can observe
right in the whole of science
that's that's the that's how it works in
the case of consciousness
in the unique case of consciousness the
thing we are trying to explain
is not publicly observable and that is
utterly unique if we want to fully bring
science into consciousness we need a
more expansive conception of the
scientific method so it doesn't mean we
can't explain consciousness
scientifically
but we need to rethink what science is
what do you mean publicly the word
publicly observable is there something
interesting to be said about the word
publicly i suppose versus privately
yeah it's tricky to define but i suppose
the data of physics are available to
anybody if um you know if there were
aliens who visited us from another
planet maybe they'd have very different
sense organs maybe they'd struggle to
understand our
art or our music
but if they were
intelligent enough to do mathematics
they could understand our physics they
could look at the data of our
experiments they could run the
experiments themselves whereas
consciousness
is it observable is it not observable in
a sense it's observable as you say we
could say it's
privately observable
i am directly aware of my own feelings
and experiences if i'm in pain
it's
it's just right there for me my pain is
just totally directly evident to me
but you from the outside
cannot directly access my pain you can
access my pain behavior
but or you can ask me
but you can't
access my pain in the way that i can
access my pain
so i think
that's a distinction
it might be difficult to totally pin it
down
how we define those things but i think
there's a fairly clear and very
important difference there so you think
there's a a kind of direct observation
that you're able to do of your pain
that i'm not so my observation
all the ways in which i can sneak up to
observing your pain is indirect
versus yours is direct
can you play devil's advocate is it
possible for me to get closer and closer
and closer
to being able to observe your pain
like all the subjective experiences
you're yours
in the way that you do
yeah i mean
so it's of course it's not that we
observe behavior and then we make an
inference
we are hardwired
to instinctively
interpret smiles as happiness
crying as
as sadness and
as we get to know someone we find it
very easy to adopt their perspective get
into their shoes
but
strictly speaking
all we have perceptual access to
is someone's behavior and
if you were just strictly speaking if
you were trying to
explain
someone's behavior that those aspects
that are publicly observable
i don't think you'd ever have recourse
to attribute consciousness you could
just postulate some kind of mechanism if
you were just trying to explain the
behavior so someone like daniel dennett
is very consistent on this
so i think for most people
what science is in the business of
is
explaining
the data of public observation
experiment if you religiously followed
that
you would not postulate consciousness
because it's it's not
a datum that's known about in that way
and daniel dennett is really consistent
on this he thinks
my consciousness cannot be empirically
verified and therefore it doesn't exist
dennett is consistent on this i think
i'm consistent on this but i think a lot
of people
have a slightly confused
uh
middleweight position on this on the one
hand
they think um
the business of science is just to
account for public observation
experiment
but on the other hand
they also believe in consciousness
without appreciating i think that
that implies that there is another datum
over and above the data of public
observation experiments namely just the
reality of feelings and experiences as
we walk along this conversation you keep
opening doors i don't want to walk into
and i will but i want to try to stay
kind of focused so you mentioned daniel
dennett let's lay it out since he sticks
to his story
upon unintended and then you stick to
yours what is your story what is your
theory of consciousness versus his can
you clarify his position
so
my view i defend the view known as pan
psychism which is the view that
consciousness
is a fundamental and ubiquitous feature
of the physical world
so it doesn't literally mean that
everything is conscious despite
the meaning of the word pan everything
psyche mind so literally that means
everything has mind
but
the typical commitment of the panzykist
is that
the fundamental building blocks of
reality
maybe fundamental particles like
electrons and quarks
have
incredibly simple forms of experience
and that the very complex experience of
the human or animal brain
is somehow rooted in or derived from
this much more simple consciousness at
the level of fundamental physics
so i mean that's that's a theory that i
would justify on the grounds that it can
account for this
datum of consciousness that it that we
are immediately aware of in our
experience
in a way that i don't think other
theories can if you asked me to contrast
that to daniel dennett i think he would
just say there is no such datum
dennett says the data for science of
consciousness is what he calls
heterophenomenology
which is
specifically defined as what we can
access from the third person perspective
including what people say
but crucially we're not treating what
they say we're not relying on their
testimony
as evidence for some unobservable uh
realm of feelings and experiences we're
just treating their what they say as
a datum of public observation
experiments that we can account for in
terms of underlying mechanisms i feel
like there's a deeper view of what
consciousness is
so you have a very clear and we'll talk
quite a bit about pan psychism
but you have a clear view of what
you know almost like a physics view of
consciousness he i think has a kind of
view that
consciousness is almost the side effect
of this
massively
parallel computation system going on in
our our brain that the the the brain is
has a model of the world and it's taking
in perceptions and it's constantly
weaving multiple stories about that
world
that's integrating the new perceptions
and the multiple stories are somehow
it's like a google doc collaborative
editing and that collaborative editing
is the actual experience
of uh
what we think of as consciousness
somehow
the editing is consciousness of this of
this
story i mean that that's that's a theory
of consciousness isn't it
the narrative theory of consciousness or
the multiple
versions editing collaborative editing
of a narrative theory of consciousness
yeah he calls it the multiple drafts
model incidentally there's a very
interesting paper just come out by a
very good philosopher luke roloff's
defending a pan psychist version of
dennett's uh multiple drafts model um
like a deeper turtle that that
establishes the difference being that
this is luke roloff's view all of the
drafts are conscious so i guess i guess
um
i guess for uh
dennett
there's sort of no fact of the matter
about which of these drafts is the
correct one
on roloff's view maybe there's no fact
of the matter about which of these
drafts is my consciousness
but
nonetheless all the drafts correspond to
some consciousness and i mean it just
sounds kind of funny i guess i think he
calls it uh danetti and pan psychism but
this but luke is a
one of the most rigorous uh and serious
philosophers
alive at the moment i think and i hate
having luke roloff's in an audience if
i'm giving a tour because he always cuts
straight to the the weakness in your
position that you hadn't thought of and
so it's nice you know psychism is
sometimes associated with fluffy
thinking but you know
contemporary pant psychists have come
out of this tradition we call analytic
philosophy which is rooted in you know
detailed rigorous argumentation and
and it is defended in that manner
yeah
those analytic philosophers are
sticklers for terminology it's very fun
very fun group to talk talk with or
yeah well i mean it gets boring if it's
if you just start and then defining
words right yeah i think starting with
defining words is good actually the
philosopher derek parfit said when
when he first was thinking about
philosophy he went to a talk in analytic
philosophy and he went to a talking
continental philosophy
and he decided that the problem with the
continental philosophy if it was really
unrigorous really and precise the
problem with the analytic philosophy is
it was just
not about anything important and he
thought there was more chance of working
within analytic philosophy and asking
some more meaningful some more profound
questions than there was in working
continental philosophy and making it
more rigorous now they're both horrific
stereotypes and you know i don't want to
get nasty emails from either of these
groups but that there's something
there's something to what he was saying
i think just a tiny tangent on
terminology
i do think that there's uh
a lot of deep insight to be discovered
by just asking questions what do we mean
by this word i remember i was taking a
a course on algorithms and data
structures in computer science and the
instructor
shout out to him ali shakafande amazing
professor i remember he asked some basic
questions like what is an algorithm
the pressure of pushing students to
answer to think deeply you know you just
woke up hungover in college or whatever
and you're tasked with answering some
deep philosophical questions about what
is an algorithm these basic questions
and they sound very simple but they're
actually very difficult and one of the
things i really value in conversation is
asking these dumb simple questions of
like
you know what is intelligence
and just continually asking that
question over and over
of um
some of the sort of biggest research in
the
researchers in the artificial
intelligence computer science space it's
actually very useful at the same time
you know it should start a terminology
and then progress where you kind of say
ah it we'll just
we'll just assume we know what we mean
by that otherwise you get the the bill
clinton situation where it's like
what is the meaning of his is whatever
he said it's like hey man did you do the
sex stuff or not
yeah
so
there's you have to both be able to talk
about
the sex stuff and the meaning of the
word is with consciousness because we
don't currently understand you know
very much
terminology discussions are very
important because
it's like you're almost trying to sneak
uh
sneak up to some deep insight by just
discussing some basic terminology
you know like what is consciousness or
even defining the different aspects of
pan psychism is fascinating but just to
linger on the um the daniel dennett
thing
what do you think about
narrative
sort of the mind constructing narratives
for ourselves so
there's nothing special about
consciousness
deeply it is some property of the human
mind
that's just
is able to tell these pretty stories
that we experience as consciousness and
that's unique perhaps to the human mind
which is i suppose what uh danielle
dennett would argue that it's
either deeply unique or
mostly unique to the human mind
it's just on the question of terminology
before right um
yes i think it used to be
the fashion among philosophers that we
had to come up with utterly precise
necessary and sufficient conditions for
each word
and then i think i think this has gone
out of fashion a bit partly because it's
just been
you know such a failure
the word knowledge in particular people
used to define knowledge as true
justified belief and then this guy
gettier had this very short paper where
he just produced some pretty conclusive
counter examples to that i think you
know he wrote very few papers but this
is just you know you have to teach this
on a on an undergraduate philosophy
course and then after that
you had a huge literature of people
trying to
address this and propose a new
definition but then someone else would
come out with counter examples and then
you get a new definition of knowledge
and counter examples and it just went on
and on and never seemed to get anywhere
so i think the thought now is
let's work out how precise we need to be
for what we're trying to do and i think
that's a healthier attitude so precision
is important but you just need to work
out how precise do we need to be for
these purposes
coming to dennett and narrative theories
i mean i think
i i think narrative theories are
a plausible contender for a theory of
the self
theory of my identity over time what
makes me
the same person in some sense today as i
was
20 years ago given that i've changed so
much physically and psychologically
one running contender is is something
like connected to the kind of stories we
tell about ourselves or maybe some story
about the psychological the chains of
psychological continuity i'm not saying
i accept such a theory but it's
plausible i don't think these theories
are good
as theories of consciousness
at least if we're taking consciousness
just to be
subjective experience pleasure pain
seeing color hearing sound
i think you know a hamster has
consciousness in that sense there's
something that it's like to be a hamster
it it feels pain if you stand on it if
you're cruel enough to do i don't know
why i gave that stand people always give
i don't know philosophers give these
very violent examples to to get the
cross consciousness and it's yeah i
don't know why that's coming probably
but anyway say mean things to the
hamster let's let's look back
it experiences pain experiences pleasure
joy
um i mean but there are some limits to
that experience of a hamster but there
is nevertheless the presence of a
subjective experience yeah consciousness
is just something i mean it's a very
ambiguous word but if we're just
using it to mean some kind of experience
some kind of in a life
that is pretty widespread in the animal
kingdom a bit difficult to say where it
stops where it starts but
you don't you certainly don't need
something as sophisticated as the
capacity to self-consciously tell
stories about yourself to be
to just have experience except for cats
who are
evil automatons that are void of
consciousness they're the fingertips of
the devil oh absolutely yeah well that
was i was taking that as read i mean
descartes thought animals were
mechanisms and humans are unique so so
animals are robots essentially in the
formulation of the car and humans are
unique
yeah so in which way would you say
humans are unique
versus
even our closest uh ancestors like is
there something special about humans
what is in your view under the pan
psychism i guess we're walking backwards
because we'll we'll have the big picture
conversation about what is pan psychism
but given
your kind of broad theory of
consciousness
what's unique about humans do you think
as a pan psychist
there is a great continuity between
humans and the rest of the universe
there's nothing
that special about human consciousness
it's just a highly evolved form
of what exists throughout the universe
so so we're very much continuous with
the rest of the physical universe what
is unique about human beings i suppose
the capacity to
reflect on our conscious experience um
plan for the future
um
the capacity i would say to respond to
reasons
as well um i mean animals in some sense
have motivations
but when a human being makes a decision
they're responding to
what philosophers call normative
considerations you know if you're saying
should i take this job in the u.s you
weigh it up you say well you know i'll
get more money i'll have maybe a better
quality of life but if i stay in the uk
i'll be closer to family and you weigh
up these considerations
i'm not
sure um
any non-human animals
quite respond to considerations of value
in that way i mean i might be reflecting
here that i'm something of an
objectivist about value i think there
are
objective facts about what we have
reason to do and what we have reason to
believe and humans have access to those
and humans have access to them and can
respond to them that's a controversial
claim you know um
many of my pan psychist brethren might
not uh
they would say the hamster
too
can look up to the stars and ponder
theoretical physics maybe not but i
think it depends what you think about
value if you have a more
humane picture of value by which i mean
relating to the philosopher david hume
who said um
reason is the slave of the passions
really we just have motivations
and what we have reason to do arises
from our motivations i'm not a human i
think there are objective facts about
what we have a reason to do and i think
we have access to them i don't think any
non-human animal
has access to
objective facts about what they have
reason to do what they have reason to
believe they don't weigh up evidence
reason is a slave of the passions that
was david hume's view yeah i mean
yeah do you want to know my problem with
fumes i had a radical conversion this is
this might not be connected it's not
connected to pan cycling but i don't i
had a radical conversion i used to have
a more humane view
uh when i was a graduate student
but i was persuaded
by uh some professors at the university
of redding where i was
that if you have a human view you have
to say
any basic
life goals are
equal
equally valid
so for example let's take someone whose
basic goal in life
is counting blades of grass right
and crucially they don't enjoy it right
this is the crucial but they get no
pleasure from it that's just their basic
goal to spend their life counting as
many blades of grass as possible not for
some greater gold that's just their
basic goal
i i want to say that that is objectively
stupid that is objectively pointless i
shouldn't say stupid movie it's
objectively pointless
uh in a way that
pursuing pleasure or pursuing someone
else's pleasure or pursuing scientific
inquiry is not pointless as soon as you
make that admission you're not a
follower of david hume anymore you think
there are
objective facts about what goals are
worth pursuing
is it possible to have a goal without
pleasure so this kind of
idea that you disjoint the two
so the
david foster wallace idea of you know
the key to life is to be unborable isn't
it possible to discover the pleasure in
everything in life
the counting of the the blades of grass
once you see the mastery the skill of it
you can discover the pleasure therefore
you know
um i guess what i'm asking is
why and when and how did you lose the
romance in grad school
[Laughter]
is that what you're trying to say
i think it may or may not be true that
it's possible to find pleasure in
everything
but i think it's also true that
people don't act solely for pleasure and
they certainly don't actually for their
own pleasure people will
suffer for things they think are
worthwhile i might you know i might
suffer for some scientific cause for
um
finding out a cure for the pandemic or
and in terms of my own pleasure i might
have less pleasure in doing that but i
think it's worthwhile it's a worthwhile
thing to do i don't i just don't think
it's the case that
everything we do is is rooted in
maximizing our own pleasure i don't
think that's even psychologically
plausible but pleasure then that's a
narrow kind of view of play that's like
a short-term pleasure but you can see
pleasure as a kind of uh
ability to hear the music in the
distance it's like yes it's difficult
now it's suffering now
but there is some greater thing beyond
the mountain
that would be joy i mean that's kind of
uh even if it's not in this life
well you know the warriors will meet in
valhalla
right the feeling that gives meaning and
fulfillment to life is not necessarily
grounded in pleasure
of like the counting of the grass it's
something else i don't know um the
struggle is a source of
deep fulfillment so like i think
pleasure needs to be kind of
thought of as
a little bit more broadly it's just kind
of
gives you this sense
it uh for a moment allows you to forget
the terror of the fact that you're going
to die
that that that's pleasure like that's
the broader view of pleasure that you
get to kind of uh
play
in the little illusion that all of this
has deep meaning
that's pleasure yeah well
but i mean you know people
sacrifice their lives uh atheists may
sacrifice their lives for the sake of
someone else or for the sake of
something important enough and
clearly in that case they're not um
doing it for the sake of their own
pleasure that's a rather dramatic
example but they can be just trivial
examples where
um
you know i i choose to
be honest rather than um
lie about something can i lose out a bit
and i um i have a bit less pleasure but
i thought it was worth doing the honest
thing or something i mean i just think
so that's a
i mean maybe you can use the word
pleasure so broadly that you're just
essentially meaning something worthwhile
but then
i think the word pleasure maybe maybe
loses its meaning
sure wow
but what do you think about the blades
of grass case what do you think about
someone who spends their life counting
blades of grass and doesn't enjoy it
so i think i personally think it's
impossible or maybe i'm not
understanding
even like the philosophical formulation
but i think it's impossible to have a
goal and not draw pleasure from it
make it worthwhile forget the word
pleasure
i think
the word gold loses meaning if i say i'm
going to count the number of pens on
this table
if i'm actively involved in the task i
will find
joy in it i will find out like i think
there's a lot of meaning and joy to be
discovered in the uh
in the skill of a task in mastering of a
skill
and and taking pride in and doing it
well i mean that's
i don't know what it is about the human
mind but there's there's some
um
joy to be discovered in the mastery of a
skill
so i think it's just impossible to count
blades of grass and not sort of have the
giro dreams of sushi
uh compelling like draws you into the
mastery of the simple task
um
yeah i suppose i mean
in a way you might think it's it's it's
just hard to imagine someone who would
spend their lives doing that but then
maybe that's just because it's so
evident
that that is a pointless task whereas
if we take this david humebu seriously
it ought to be you know a totally
possible life goal whereas i mean i
yeah i guess i just find it hard to
shake the idea that
some ways of
um some life goals are more worthwhile
than others and it doesn't mean you know
that there's a one single way you should
lead your life but
pursuing knowledge helping people um
pursuing your own pleasure to an extent
are a worthwhile things to do
in the in a way that you know for
example i have i'm a little bit
ocd i i still feel inclined to
walk on cracks in the pavement or do it
symmetrically like if i
step on a crack with my left foot i feel
the need to do it my right foot and
um
i think that's kind of pointless it's
something i feel the urge to do but it's
pointless whereas
other things i choose to do i think
there's
it's worth doing and
um it's hard to make sense of
metaphysically what could possibly
ground that how could we know about
these facts but
that's the starting point for me i don't
know i think you walking
on the sidewalk in a way that's
symmetrical
brings uh order to the world like if you
weren't doing that the world might fall
apart and you it feels like that
i think there's there's um there's
meaning in that like you
embracing the full
like the full experience of that you
living the richness to that as if it has
meaning will give meaning to it and then
whatever genius comes of that as you as
a one little intelligent aunt will make
a better life for everybody else perhaps
i'm defending the the blades of grass
example because i can literally imagine
myself enjoying this task as somebody
who's right ocd in a certain kind of way
and quantitative but now you're ruining
the exam because you imagine someone
enjoying it i'm imagining someone who
doesn't enjoy it we don't want a life
that's
just full of pleasure like we just sit
there you know
having a big sugar high all the time we
want a life where we do things that are
worthwhile
if
for something to be worthwhile just is
for it to be a basic life goal
then
um
that
that mode of reflection doesn't really
make sense we can't really think did i
do things worthwhile on the on the david
hume type picture
all it is for something to be worthwhile
is it was a basic goal of yours or
derived from a basic goal and
yeah
yeah i mean i i think goal and
worthwhile aren't
i think goal's a boring word a more sort
of existential is like
did you ride the roller coaster of life
did you fully experience life
that
and in that sense i mean the blaze of
grass
is something that could be deeply joyful
and that's
in that way i think suffering can be
joyful in the full context of life it's
the rollercoaster of life like without
suffering without struggle without pain
without depression or sadness there's
not the highs i mean that's just yeah
that's the up thing about life is
that um
the lows
really make the highs
that much
richer and deeper and
and like tastes better right like the
like i was i tweeted this i was i
couldn't sleep and i was like late at
night
and i know it's like uh obvious
statement
but
like every
love story
eventually
you know ends in loss
in tragedy
so like this feeling of love
at the end there's always going to be
tragedy even if it's the most amazing
lifelong love with another human being
one of you is going to die
and i don't know which is worse
but both both are not going to be pretty
and so
that
the sense that it's finite the sense
that it's going to end in a low
that gives like richness
to those kind of evenings when you
realize this thing ends this
thing ends
the the feeling that it ends
the the that that that bad taste that
bad feeling that it ends gives meaning
gives joy gives i don't know pleasure
this loaded word but
gives some kind of uh deep pleasure to
the experience when it's good
and i i mean and that's the blades of
grass
you know they they have that to me
um
but you're perhaps right that it's uh
like uh reducing it to a set of goals or
something like that
is is um kind of removing the magic of
life because i think what makes counting
the blaze of grass joyful is
it's just because it's life
okay so it sounds like you it sounds
like you reject
the david hume type picture anyway
because you're saying
just because you have it as a goal
that's what it is to be worthwhile but
you're saying no it's because it's
engaging with life riding the roller
coaster
um
so that does sound like in some sense
there are facts
independent of our personal goal choices
about what it means to live a good life
and i mean coming back full circle to
the start of the start of this was what
makes us different to animals i don't
think at the end of a hamster's life
it thinks did i ride the roller coaster
did i really live life to the full that
is not a mode of reflection that's
available to non-human animals so
what do you think is the role of death
in uh in all of this
the the fear of death
does that interplay with consciousness
does
this self-reflection
do you think
there's some
deep connection between this ability to
contemplate the fact that the our flame
of
of uh
consciousness eventually goes out
yeah i don't think unfortunately pan
psychism
helps particularly with life after death
because you know for the pan cyclist
there's nothing supernatural there's
nothing
beyond the physical all there is really
is ultimately particles and fields it's
just that we think the ultimate nature
of particles and fields is consciousness
but
i guess when um
when the uh
the matter in my brain
ceases to be ordered in a way that
sustains the particular kind of
consciousness
uh i enjoy in waking life then
in some sense i will i i will cease to
be although i do that the final chapter
of my book galileo's era is more
experimental so the first four chapters
are the
cold-blooded case for the panzerkist
view is that the best
solution to the hard problem of
consciousness the last chapter we talk
about meaning yeah i talk about meaning
talk about free will and i talk about
mystical experiences so
i always want to emphasize that
pan psychism is not necessarily
connected to anything spiritual you know
a lot of people defending this view like
david sharma's or luke roloffs are just
total atheist secularists right they
don't believe in
any kind of transcendent reality they
just believe in
feelings you know mundane consciousness
and think that needs explaining in our
conventional scientific approach can't
cut it
but
if
for independent reasons you are
motivated to some spiritual
picture of reality then maybe a
panzerkiss view is is more consonant
with that so if you
if you have a mystical experience where
you um
it seems to you in this experience that
there is this
higher form of consciousness at the root
of all things
if you're a materialist you've got to
think that's a delusion you know there's
just something in your brain making you
think that it's not real
but if you're a pan psychist and you
already think
the fundamental nature of reality is
constituted of consciousness it's not
that much of a leap to think that
this higher form of consciousness you
seem to apprehend in the mystical
experience is part of that underlying
reality
and you know in in many different
cultures experienced meditators
have claimed to have experiences
in which it becomes apparent to them
that
there is an element of consciousness
that is universal so this is sometimes
called universal consciousness
so
on this view
your mind and my mind are not
uh totally distinct
uh each of our individual conscious
minds is built upon the foundations of
universal consciousness and universal
consciousness as it exists in me is
one and the same thing as universal
consciousness as it exists in you
so
i've never had one of these experiences
but if one is a pancychist i think one
is more open to that possibility i don't
see why it shouldn't be the case that
that is part of the nature of
consciousness and maybe something that
is apparent in certain
deep states of meditation and so what i
explore in the experimental final
chapter of my book is that could allow
for
a kind of impersonal
life after death because if that view is
true then even when the
particular
aspects of my conscious experience fall
away
that
element of universal consciousness at
the core of my identity would continue
to exist
so i'd sort of be as it were absorbed
into universal consciousness so i mean
buddhists and hindu mystics
try to meditate to get rid of all the
bad karma to
be absorbed into universal consciousness
it could be that
if uh if there's no karma if there's no
reverb maybe everyone gets enlightened
when they die maybe you uh just
sink back into universal consciousness
so i i also coming back to morality
suggests this could provide some kind of
basis for
altruism or non-egotism because if you
think
egotism implicitly assumes that we are
utterly distinct individuals whereas on
this view we we're not we overlap to an
extent that something at the core of our
being is even in this life we overlap
that would be this view that
some experienced meditators claim
becomes apparent to them that there is
something at the core of my identity
that is one and the same as
the thing at the core of your identity
uh this universal consciousness
yeah there is something very
like you and i in this conversation
there's a few people listening to this
all of us are in a kind of
single mind together
there's some small aspect of that
and
or maybe a big aspect about us humans
so certainly in the space of ideas we
kind of um
meld together
for time at least in a conversation
and kind of play with that idea and then
we're clearly all thinking like if i say
pink elephant
there's going to be a few people that
are now visualizing a pink elephant
we're all thinking
about that pink elephant together
we're all in the room together thinking
about this pink outfit and we're like
rotating it um like you know in our
minds together what is that
that pink out does that
is there a different instantiation of
that pink elephant in everybody's mind
or is it the same elephant and we have
the same mind exploring that elephant
now if we in our mind start petting that
elephant like touching it that
experience that we're now like thinking
what that would feel like
what's that is that all of us
experiencing that together or is that
separate so like there's some aspect of
the togetherness that almost seems
fundamental to civilization to society
hopefully that's not too strong but to
like some of the
fundamental properties of the human mind
it feels like the social aspect is
really important
we call it social because we think of us
as individual minds interacting but if
we're just like one collective mind
with like fingertips they're like
touching each other as it's trying to
explore the elephant
but that could be just in the realm of
ideas and intelligence and not in the
realm of consciousness and it's
interesting to see maybe it is in the
realm of consciousness yeah so
it's obviously certainly true in some
sense
that there are these phenomena that
you're talking about of
collective consciousness in some sense i
suppose the question is
how
ontologically serious do we want to be
about those things by which i mean are
they just a construction of out of our
minds and the fact that we interact in
the
standard standardly scientifically
accepted ways
or is as someone like rupert sheldrake
would think that there is some
metaphysical reality there are some
fields beyond the scientifically
understood ones that are somehow
communicating this um
i mean i think that i mean the view i
was describing was that this element
we're supposed to have in common is
is some sort of pure impersonal
consciousness or something rather than
so actually i mean an interesting figure
is the the australian philosopher mirial
buhari who defends a kind of
mystical conception of reality rooted in
uh advice of a dante mysticism
but like me she's from this tradition of
analytic philosophy and so she defends
this in this you know incredibly precise
rigorous way she defends the idea that
we should think of experienced
meditators as
uh providing expert testimony
so you know i think
humans cause a causing climate breakdown
i have no idea the science behind it you
know i but i trust the experts or you
know that the universe is 14 billion
years old you know most of our knowledge
is based on expert testimony and she
thinks we should think of
experienced meditators these people who
are telling us about this universal
consciousness at the core of our being
as a relevant kind of expert and so she
wants to defend you know the rational
acceptability of this mystical
conception of reality so it's what you
know i think
we shouldn't be a shame you know we
shouldn't be worried about
dealing with certain views as long as
it's done with rigor and seriousness you
know i think sometimes terms like i
don't know new age or something can
function a bit like racist terms you
know a racist term
picks out a group of people but then
implies certain negative characteristics
so people use this term you know to pick
out a certain set of views like mystical
conceptual reality and and imply it's
kind of
fluffy thinking or but you know you read
mirial bahari you read luke roloff's
this is serious rigorous thought whether
you agree with him or not obviously it's
hugely controversial and so you know the
enlightenment ideal
is to follow the evidence and the
arguments where they lead
but it's kind of very hard for human
beings to do that i think we get stuck
in some conception of
how we think science ought to look um
and
and um you know people talk about
religion as a crutch but i think a
certain kind of scientism
a certain conception of how science is
supposed to be gets into people's
identity and their sense of themselves
and their security um
and
makes things hard if you're a panzerkiss
and even the word expert
becomes a kind of uh
crutch i mean you use the word expert
uh you have some kind of conception of
what expertise means
uh oftentimes that's
you know connected with a degree a
particularly prestigious university or
something like that or
or um it's it's you know uh expertise is
a funny one i i've i've noticed that
anybody sort of that claims they're an
expert is usually not the expert the the
biggest quote unquote expert
that i've ever met are the ones that are
truly humble so the humility is a really
good sign
of somebody
who's traveled the long road and been
humbled by how little they know
so some of the best people in the world
at whatever the thing they've spent
their life doing are the ones that are
ultimately
humble in the face of it all so like
just being
humble
how little we know even if we travel a
lifetime
i do like the idea
i mean treating sort of uh like what is
it psychonauts like an expert witness
you know people who have traveled
with the help of dmt to another place
where they
got some deep understanding of something
and their insight is perhaps as valuable
as the insight of somebody who ran
rigorous psychological studies at
princeton university or something
like those those psychonauts they have
wisdom if it's done rigorously
uh which you can also do rigorously
within the university within the studies
now with the with psilocybin and those
kinds of things yeah that's
fascinating still probably the best one
of the best works on mystical experience
is
the chapter in william james's varieties
of religious experiences
and most of it is um just a
psychological study of trying to define
the characteristics of mystical
experience as a psychological type
but at the end he considers the question
if you have a mystical experience is it
rational to trust it to trust that it's
telling you something about reality and
he makes an interesting argument he says
if you say no
you're kind of applying a double
standard
because we all think it's okay to trust
our
normal sensory experiences
but we have no way of
getting outside of ourselves to prove
that our sensory experiences correspond
to an external reality we could be in
the matrix this could be a very vivid
dream uh you know you could say or we do
science but
a scientist only
gets their data by
experiencing the results of their
experiments and then the question arises
again how do you know that corresponds
to a real world so he thinks there's a
sort of double standard in saying
it's okay to trust our ordinary sensory
experiences but it's not okay for the
person on dmt to trust those experiences
it's very philosophically difficult to
say
why is it okay in the one case
and
not the other so i think there's an
interesting argument there but i would
like to just defend experts a little bit
i mean i agree it's very difficult
but especially in an age i guess where
there's so much information
i do think it's important
to have
some
protection of
sources of information academic
institutions that we can trust
and then that's difficult because of
course there are non-academics who do
know what they're talking about but like
if i'm
interested in knowing about biology you
know you can't research everything
so i think we have to have
some sense of
who are the experts
we can trust the people who've spent a
lot of time reading all the material
that people have read written um
thinking about it
having their
their views torn apart by other people
working in the field i think that is
very important and also to protect that
from conflicts of interest there is a
so-called think tank in the uk called
the institute of economic affairs who
are always on the bbc as
experts on economic questions and they
do not declare who funds them right so
we don't know who's paying the piper i
think you know you shouldn't be allowed
to call yourself a think tank if you're
not totally transparent about who's
funding you so i think that's the and i
mean this connects to pan psychism
because i think the reason people
you know
worry about unorthodox ideas is because
they worry about how do we know when
we're just losing control or losing
discipline so i do think we need to
somehow protect
um
academic institutions as
sources of information that we can trust
and you know in philosophy there's
there's um you know there's no not much
consensus on everything but you can at
least know
what people
who have put the time in to read all the
stuff
what what they think about these issues
i think that is important to push back
in your pushback
who are the experts
on covet
they're getting into dangerous territory
now well let me just speak to it because
i am walking through that dangerous
territory
i'm allergic to the word expert
because
in my
simple mind
it um
kind of rhymes with ego
there's uh something about experts
if we allow too much
to to have a category expert and place
certain people in them those people
sitting on the throne start to believe
it
and they start to communicate with that
energy and the humility starts to
dissipate
i think there is
a
value in a lifelong mastery
of a skill and the pursuit of knowledge
within a very specific discipline but
the moment you have your name on an
office the moment you're an expert
i think you destroy the very
aspect
the very value of that journey towards
knowledge so some of it probably just
reduces to like skillful communication
like of
communicate in a way that shows humility
that shows an open-mindedness
that shows an ability to really hear
what a lot of people are saying
so in the case of kovid what i've
noticed and this is true this is
probably true with pan psychism as well
is
so-called experts
and they are extremely knowledgeable and
many of them are colleagues of mine
they dismiss
what
millions of people are saying on the
internet
without having looked into it
with empathy and rigor honestly
understand what are the arguments being
made they say like there's not enough
time to explore all those things like
there's so much stuff out there
yeah i think that's intellectual
laziness if if you don't have enough
time then don't speak so strongly with
dismissal
feel bad about it be apologetic about
the fact that you don't have enough time
to explore the uh the evidence for
example with the heat i got with francis
collins
is that he kind of said that um lab
league
he kind of
dismissed it
showing that he didn't really deeply
explore all the sort of the the the huge
amount of uh circumstantial evidence
that's out there the battles that are
going on out there there's a lot of
people really tensely discussing this
and being um
showing humility in the face
of that battle of ideas i think is
really important and i i just been very
disappointed in
so-called expertise in the space of
science in showing humility and showing
humanity and kindness and empathy
towards other human beings that's that's
at the same time obviously
i love
jira dreams of sushi lifelong pursuit of
like getting
like in computer science don knuth
like some of my biggest heroes are
people that like when nobody else cares
they stay on one topic
for their whole life and they just find
the beautiful little things about their
puzzles they keep solving and yes
sometimes a virus happens or something
happens where that person
with their puzzles
becomes like the center of the whole
world because that puzzles becomes all
of a sudden really important but still
there's possibilities on them to show
humility and to be open-minded to the
fact that they even if they spent their
whole life doing it even if their whole
community
is telling them giving them awards and
giving them citations and giving them
all kinds of stuff where like they're
bowing down before them how smart they
are they still know
nothing relative to all the stuff the
mysteries that are out there yeah i
wonder how much we're disagreeing i mean
these are totally valid issues and of
course
expertise goes wrong in all sorts of
ways it's totally fallible i suppose i
would just say
what is the alternative what do we just
say
all information is is equal because i
you know as a voter
i've got to decide who to vote for and
that you know i've got to evaluate
um and i can't look into
all of the economics and all of the
relevant science and
um
so
i just think there's i think in
maybe it's like um churchill said about
democracy you know it's the worst system
of government apart from all the rest
i think about psychisms actually it's
the worst theory of consciousness apart
from all the rest but um you know i just
think expertise the peer review system i
think
it's terrible in so many ways
yes people should show more humility but
i i can't see
a viable alternative i think philosopher
and williams had a really nice nuanced
discussion of the the problems of titles
but then how they also function in a
society
um they do have some positive function
the very first time i lectured in
philosophy
um
before i got a
a professorship um
was
teaching at a at a continuing education
college so it's kind of kind of retired
people who want to um
learn some more things and i just
totally pitched it too high and gate
talked about bernard williams on on
titles and hierarchies and these kind of
people in the 70s and 80s were just
instantly started interrupting saying
what is philosophy and um it was a
disaster
and i just remember in the break
a sort of elderly lady come up and said
i've decided to take egyptology instead
so but that was uh that was my uh
introduction to teaching anyway but sort
of titles and accomplishments
is uh is a nice is a nice starting point
but doesn't buy you the whole
thing so and
you don't get to just say this is true
because because i'm an expert you still
have to convince people one of the
things i really like to practice martial
arts yeah
and uh
for people who don't know it's
brazilian jiu jitsu is one of them and
you you sometimes wear these pajamas
pajama looking things and you wore a
belt so i happen to be a black belt and
in brazilian jiu jitsu and i also train
in what's called nogi so you don't wear
the pajamas
and when you don't wear the pajamas
nobody knows what rank you are
nobody knows if you're a black bolt or a
white belt or if you're a complete
beginner or not right and when you um
wear the pajamas called the ghee uh you
wear the rank and people treat you very
differently when like when they see my
black belt they treat me differently
they kind of
defer to my expertise if if they're
kicking my ass
that's probably because
uh like i am working on something
like new or maybe i'm letting them win
but when there's no belts and there's it
doesn't matter if i've been doing this
for 15 years it doesn't matter none of
it matters what matters is the raw
interaction of just trying to kick each
other's ass and seeing like what is this
chess game
like of human chess
who what are the ideas that we're
playing with and i think
there's a dance there
yes it's valuable to know a person as a
black belt when
you take consideration of the advice of
different people me versus somebody
who's only practiced for like a couple
of days
but at the same time
the raw practice of ideas that is combat
and the raw practice of exchange of
ideas that is science
needs to often throw away expertise and
in communicating like there's an other
thing to science and expertise which is
leadership
it's not just
so the scientific method in the review
process is this rigorous battle of ideas
between scientists but there's also a
stepping up and inspiring the world and
communicating ideas to the world and
that skill of communication
i suppose that's my biggest criticism of
so-called experts in science is there
just shitty communication absolutely
yeah well i can totally i get very
frustrated with philosophers
not reaching out more i mean i i think
i think it might be partly that we're
trained to get get water tight arguments
you know respond to all objections and
as you do that
eventually it gets more complicated and
the jargon comes in and
um but then if so to write and write a
more accessible book or article you have
to loosen the argument a bit and then we
worry that other philosophers will think
oh that's a really crap argument so i
mean the way i did it i wrote my
academic book first it's just some
fundamental reality
and then a more accessible book
galileo's era where the arguments you
know not as rigorously worked out so
then i can say the proper arguments that
you know the further arguments there but
but i guess it's brilliantly done by the
way like there's that that's such a so
so for people don't know you first wrote
consciousness and fundamental reality so
that's the academic book also very good
i flew through it last night uh bought
it and then obviously the popular book
is uh galileo's era foundations for a
new science of consciousness that's kind
of the right way to do it yeah to show
that you're legit to your community to
the world by doing the book that's
nobody going to read
and then doing a popular book
that everybody's going to read that's
cool well i try now every time i write
an academic article
i try to write a more accessible
version i mean the thing i've been
working on recently just because
there's this argument um
so there there's a certain argument from
the cosmological fine-tuning of the laws
of physics for life to the multiverse
that's quite popular physicists like max
tegmark
um
there's there's there's an
argument in philosophy journals that
that that's there's a fallacious
line of reasoning
going on there from the fine-tuning to
the multiverse now that argument is from
20 30 years ago and it's you know
discussed in academic philosophy nobody
knows about it and there is huge
interest in this fine-tuning stuff
scientists wanting to argue for the
multiverse uh theists wanting to say
this is evidence for god and nobody
knows about this argument which tries to
show that it's fallacious reasoning to
go from the fine tuning to the
multiverse so i wrote a piece for
scientific american explaining this
argument
uh to a more general audience and you
know that's it just it just really
irritates me that
uh it's just buried in these technical
uh
journal articles and uh and nobody knows
about it but um just you know final
thing on that on
um you know i look i don't disagree with
anything you said and that's kind of
really beautiful that martial arts
example and thinking
how that could be analogous but i i
think it's very rare
to find a good philosopher
who hasn't had
who hasn't given a talk
to other philosophers and and had
objections raised i was going to say
have it torn apart but
that's maybe thinking of it in the
slightly the wrong way but
have the best objections raised to it
you know and
that's why
that that is an important formative
process that you go through as an
academic that the greatest minds
um
starting a philosophy degree for example
won't have gone through
um
probably in except in very rare cases
just
won't have that the skills required but
part of it's just fun to disagree and
dance with uh
i think
to elaborate on what you're saying in
agreement
not just gone through that but continue
to go through that absolutely that's i
would say the biggest problem with quote
unquote expertise
is that there's a certain point
where you get because it sucks like is
martial arts is a good example that it
sucks to get your ass kicked yeah like i
um there's a temptation i still go like
i train
you know you're getting older too but
also there's killers out there in in
both the space of martial arts and the
space of science
and i think that once you become a
professor like more and more senior and
more and more respected
i don't know if you get your ass kicked
in the space of ideas as often i don't
know if you allow yourself
to truly expose yourself if you do
that's a great
like sign of of a
humble brilliant mind it's constantly
exposing yourself to that i think you do
because i think there's there's graduate
students who want to
you know find the objection to sort of
uh write their paper or make their mark
and
yeah i i think
everyone still gives talks or should
gives talk give talks and people are
wanting to
work out if there are any weaknesses to
your position so
yeah i think that generally works out
there is also kind of um
who do you give the talks to hmm
so i mean within communities
it's a little cluster of people that
argue and bicker
but what are they arguing about
they take a bunch of stuff
a bunch of basic assumptions as
agreement
and they
heatedly argue about certain ideas the
question is how opener that that's
actually kind of like fun that's like
no offense sorry we're sticking on this
martial arts thing it's like people who
practice aikido or
certain martial arts that don't truly
test themselves in the in the cage in
combat
so it's like it's fun to argue about
like certain things when you're in your
own community but you don't test those
ideas in the full
uh context of science
in the full like
seriousness the the rigor
of the sometimes like the real world one
of my favorite fields is psychology
there's often places within psychology
where you're kind of doing these studies
and arguing about stuff that's done in
the lab
the arguments
are
almost disjoint from real human behavior
because it's so much easier to study
human behavior in the lab you just kind
of stay there and that's where the
arguments are and so vision science is a
good example like studying uh eye
movement and how we perceive the world
and all that kind of stuff it's so much
easier to study in a lab that we don't
consider
we say that's going to be what the
science of vision is going to be like
and we don't consider the science
division in the actual real world the
engineering of yeah i don't know and so
i think that's where
exposing yourself to out of the box
ideas yeah that's the most painful
that's the most important i mean group
thing can be a terrible thing in
philosophy as well but because you're
not
to the same extent beholden to evidence
and refutation from the evidence that
you are in the sciences uh it's a more
subtle process of evaluation and so more
susceptible i think to group think yeah
i agree it's a danger
we've talked about it a million times
but uh let's let's try to sort of do
that old uh basic terminology
definitions
what is pan psychism like what are the
different
ways you can try to to think about to
define pan psychos and
in contrast to uh
naturalistic dualism and materialism and
other kind of views of consciousness
yeah so that
you've basically laid out the different
options so i guess
probably still the dominant view is
materialism that
roughly that we can explain
consciousness in in the terms of
physical science wholly explain it just
in terms of
the electrochemical signaling in the
brain
dualism the polar opposite view
that consciousness is
non-physical outside of the physical
workings of the body in the brain
although closely connected
um and you know when i studied
philosophy we were taught basically they
were the two options you had to choose
right either you thought it you were
duelist and you
thought it was separate from the
physical or you thought it was just
electrochemical signaling and yeah i
became very disillusioned because i
think there are big problems with both
of these options
so i think the attraction of pan
psychism is it's kind of a middle way
it agrees with the materialist that
there's just the physical world
ultimately there's just particles and
fields
but
the pan pancychist
thinks there's there's more to the
physical than what physical science
reveals and that
the ultimate nature of the physical
world is constituted of consciousness so
consciousness is not outside of the
physical as the duelist thinks it's
embedded in
um underlies
the kind of
description of the world we get from
physics
what what are the problems of
materialism and dualism
starting with materialism
i
it's a huge debate
but i think that the core of it is that
physical science works with a purely
quantitative description of the physical
world
whereas consciousness
essentially involves qualities if you
think about the smell of coffee or the
taste of mint or
the deep red you experience as you watch
a sunset
i think these qualities
can't be captured in the purely
quantitative language of physical
science and so as long as your
description of the brain is framed in
the purely quantitative descript
quantitative language of neuroscience
you'll just
leave out these qualities and that's
really leave out consciousness itself
and then dualism
so i've actually changed my mind a
little bit on this since i wrote the
book so i mean i argued in the book that
we have
pretty good experimental grounds for
doubting dualism
and roughly the idea was
if dualism were true if there was say an
immaterial
mind
impacting on the brain every second of
waking life that this would really show
up in our neuroscience you know there'd
be all sorts of
things happening in the brain that had
no
physical explanation it would be like a
a poltergeist was playing with the brain
um
but actually
and so the you know the fact that we
don't find that
is a strong and ever-growing inductive
argument against dualism but actually
you know the more i talk to
neuroscientists and read neuroscience
and we you know we have a durham my
university an interdisciplinary
consciousness group
i i don't think we know enough about the
brain about the workings of the brain to
make that argument
um i think we know we know a lot about
the basic chemistry
um
how neurons fire
neurotransmitters action potentials
things like that we know a fair bit
about
large scale functions of the brain what
different bits of the brain do
but what we're almost clueless on is
how those large scale functions are
realized at the cellular level how it
works
um you know people get quite excited
about brain scans but
it's very low resolution you know every
pixel on a brain scan corresponds to
5.5 million neurons and we're only um
we're only 70 of the way through
constructing a connectome for the for
the maggot brain
which has is it 10 000 or 100 000
neurons but you know the brain has 86
billion neurons
so i think we'd have to know a lot more
about
how the brain works
how these functions are realized
um
before we could assess whether they can
be the dynamics of the brain can be
completely explicated in terms of
underlying chemistry or physics so um
you know we'd have to do more
engineering before we could uh figure
that out and there are people with other
proposals um
someone i got to know martin picard at
columbia university who has the uh
psychobiology mitochondrial lab there
and is experimentally exploring the
hypothesis that mitochondria in the
brain should be on the sort of sort of
social networks
perhaps as an alternative to reducing it
to underlying chemistry and physics
so so i i'm less
it is ultimately an empirical question
redulism is true i'm less convinced that
we know the answer to that question at
this stage
i think still as scientists and
philosophers we want to try and find the
simplest most parsimonious theory of
reality
and dualism is still a pretty
inelegant
unparsimonious theory you know reality
is divided up into
the purely physical properties and these
consciousness properties and they're
radically different kinds of things
whereas the pan psychist offers a much
more simple unified picture of reality
so i think it's still the view to be
preferred
you know to put it very simply why
believe in two kinds of thing
when you can just get away with one and
materialism is also very simple but
you're saying it doesn't explain
something that seems pretty important
yeah so i think materialism can't you
know we try science is about trying to
find the simplest theory that accounts
for the data i don't think materialism
can account for the data
maybe dualism can account for the data
but pan psychism is simpler it can
account for the data and it's simpler
what is pan psychism
so in its broadest definition it's the
view that
consciousness is a fundamental um and
ubiquitous feature of the physical world
like a law of physics what should we be
imagining what do you what do you think
the different flavors of how that
actually takes shape in the context of
what we know about physics and science
and the universe so in the simplest form
of it the fundamental building blocks of
reality perhaps electrons and quarks
have incredibly simple forms of
experience and the very complex
experience of the human or animal brain
is somehow
rooted in or derived from
these very simple
forms of experience at the level of
basic physics but i mean maybe the
crucial bit about
the kind of pan psychism i defend
what it does is it
it takes the
standard approach to the problem of
consciousness
and turns it on its head right so the
standard approach is to think um
we start with matter
and we think how do we get consciousness
out of matter so i don't think that
problem can be solved for reasons i've
kind of hinted out we could maybe go
into more detail
but the pancitis does it the other way
around
they start with consciousness and try to
get mata out of consciousness so the
idea is basically
at the fundamental level of reality
there are just
um networks of very simple conscious
entities
um
but these conscious entities because
they're behave they have very simple
kinds of experience they behave in
predictable ways
through their interactions they realize
certain mathematical structures
and then the idea is those mathematical
structures just are
the structures identified by physics
so
when we think about these simple
conscious entities in terms of the
mathematical structures they realize we
call them particles we call them fields
we call
the their properties mass spin and
charge
but really there's just
these very simple conscious entities and
their experiences so in this way we get
physics
out of consciousness i don't think you
can get consciousness out of physics but
i think it's pretty easy to get physics
out of consciousness well
i'm a little confused by why
you need to get physics out of
consciousness i did i mean to me it
sounds like
pan psychism
unites consciousness and physics i mean
physics is is the
mathematical science of describing
everything so physics should be able to
describe consciousness
pan psychism in my understanding
proposes
is that physics doesn't currently do so
but can in the future i mean it seems
like consciousness
you have like stephen wolfram who's all
these people who are trying to develop
um
theories of everything
mathematical frameworks within which to
describe how we get all the reality that
we perceive around us
to me there's no reason why that kind of
framework cannot also include
some
accurate
precise description
of whatever
simple consciousness
characteristics are present there at the
lowest level if
uh pan psychist theories have uh truth
to them so like to me it is physics you
said kind of physics emerges you by
which you mean like the the basic four
laws of physics that as we currently
know them the standard model quantum
mechanics general relativity that that
emerges from
the base consciousness layer that's what
you mean yeah so maybe the way i phrased
it made it sound like these things are
more separate than they are what i was
trying to
uh address was a common
misunderstanding of panseikism that it's
a sort of dualistic theory
that
um
the idea is that particles have their
physical properties like mass spin and
charge and these other funny
consciousness properties so that the
physicists sabine hossenfelder had a
blog post critiquing pan psychism maybe
a couple of years ago now that got a
fair bit of traction and she was
interpreting psychism in this way and
then her thought was
well look if particles had these funny
consciousness properties then it would
show up in our physics like the standard
model of particle physics would make
false predictions because its
predictions are based wholly on the
physical properties if there were also
these consciousness properties uh we'd
get different predictions but that's a
misunderstanding of the view the view is
it's not that there are two kinds of
property that mass spin and charge
are
forms of consciousness how do we make
sense of that because
actually when you look at what physics
physics tells us it's really just
telling us
about behavior about what stuff does
i sometimes put it by saying uh doing
physics is like
playing chess when you don't care what
the pieces are made of you're just
interested in what moves you can make so
physics tells us what mass spin and
charge do
um
but it doesn't tell us
what they are
so
so the idea the experience of mass so
the idea is yeah mass in its nature is a
very simple form of consciousness so
yeah physics in a sense is complete i
think because it tells us
what everything at the fundamental level
does it describes its causal capacities
but
for the panzerkist at least physics
doesn't tell us what matter
is it tells us what it does but not what
it is
to push back on the thing i think she's
criticizing is it also possible so i
understand what you're saying but is it
also possible that particles have
another property like consciousness i
don't understand the criticism we would
be able to detect it in our uh
experiments well no if you're not
looking for it
there's a lot of stuff that are uh
orthogonal
like if you're not looking for the stuff
you're not going to detect it because
like all of our basic empirical science
through its recent history and yes the
history of science is quite recent
uh has been very kind of focused on
billiard balls colliding
and uh from that understanding how
gravity works but like we just haven't
integrated
other possibilities into this i i don't
think there will be conflicting whether
you are observing consciousness or not
or exploring some of these ideas
um i don't think that affects the rest
of the physics the the mass the energy
the
all the different kind of
like the hierarchy of different
particles and so on how they interact i
i don't think
it feels like consciousness is something
orthogonal like
very much distinct it's it's the
quantitative versus the qualitative
there's there's something quite distinct
that we're just uh almost like another
dimension that we're just completely
ignoring
there might be a way of responding to
sabine and to say well
there could be properties
of particles that don't show up in the
specific circumstances in which
physicists investigate particles you
know my my colleague the philosopher of
science nancy cartwright he's got this
book how the laws of physics lie where
she says you know physicists explore
uh things in very specific circumstances
and then
in an unwarranted way generalize that
but i mean i guess i was thinking
sabine's criticism actually just misses
the mark in a more basic way
her point is we shouldn't think there
are any more properties to particles
other than those the standard model
attributes to them
pan psychics will say yeah sure there
aren't there are just the properties the
physical properties like mass spin and
charge that the standard model
attributes them it's just that
we have a different philosophical view
as to the nature of it so those
properties the turtles they're sitting
on top of another turtle and that big
turtle is consciousness that's what
you're saying but
i'm just saying i don't it's possible
that's true it's possible also that
consciousness is just another turtle
playing with the others
like it's just not interacting in the
ways that we've been observing i don't
in fact to me that's more compelling
because then that's going to be
well no i think both are very compelling
but um
it feels like it's more within the reach
of empirical validation if it's yet
another property of particles that we're
just not observing if it's like
the the thing from which matter and
energy and
physics emerges
like
it makes it that much more difficult
because
to investigate how you get from that
base layer of consciousness to the
wonderful
little spark of consciousness complexity
and beauty that is the human
being i don't know if you're necessarily
trying to get there but one of the
beautiful
things to get at with pan psychism or
with a solid theory of consciousness is
to answer the question
how do you engineer the thing
yeah how do you get from
nothing
vacuum in the lab
if there is that consciousness based
layer how do you start engineering
organisms that have consciousness in
them yeah
or the reverse of that describing how
does consciousness emerge in the human
being from uh from conception
from from a stem cell to the hopeful
neurobiology that builds from that how
do you get this full rich experience of
cautiousness that humans have it just
um it feels like that's the dream and if
consciousness is just another player in
the game of physics it feels more
amenable to our scientific understanding
of it um that's interesting i mean i
guess it's supposed to be a kind of
identity claim here that physics tells
us
what matter does
consciousness is what matter is so so
matter is sort of what consciousness
does
so at the bottom level there is just
consciousness and conscious things
they're just these simple things with
their experiences and that is their
total nature so in that sense it's not
another player it's just
all there is really and then we describe
in physics we describe that at a certain
level of abstraction we just we we
capture what bertrand russell who was
the inspiration for a lot of this um
calls the causal skeleton of the world
so you know physics is just interesting
the causal skeleton of the world it's
not interested in the sort of flesh and
blood although that that's maybe
suggesting separation again too much
all metaphors fail in the end but um
yeah so
so yeah you totally write ultimately
what we want to explain is how
our consciousness and the consciousness
of other animals comes out of this if we
can't do that then
it's game over but
i i think it
maybe makes more sense it on the
identity claim that if if matter at the
fundamental level just is forms of
consciousness then we can perhaps make
sense of how those simple forms of
consciousness in some way combine in
some way to make
the consciousness we know and love
that's the dream yeah so
i guess the question is um
so the reason you can describe like the
reason you have material engineering
material science
is because you have from physics
to chemistry like you keep going up and
up
in
levels of complexity
in order to describe
objects that we have in our
human world
and it would be nice to do the same
thing for consciousness to come up with
the chemistry of consciousness right
like how
like
how do the different particles interact
to create more
uh greater complexity so you can do this
kind of thing for life like what is life
like living organisms
at which point does do living organisms
become living
what like what how do you know
if i give you a thing
that that thing is living and there's
there's a lot of people working on this
kind of idea and uh some of it has to do
with the levels of complexity and so on
it'd be nice to know like
measuring different degrees of
consciousness as you get into a bigger
more and more complex objects
and and that's i mean that's what
chemistry like bigger and bigger
conscious molecules
and to see how that leads to organisms
and then organisms like start to
collaborate together like they do inside
our human body to create the full human
body to do those kinds of experiments
would be
that it seems like that would be kind of
a goal that's what i mean by player in a
game of physics
as opposed to like the base lay if it's
just the base layer it becomes harder to
track it as you get from physics to
chemistry to biology to psychology
yeah
in every case apart from consciousness i
would say what we're interested in is
behavior
uh we're interested in
explaining behavioral functions it's at
the level of fundamental physics we're
interested in capturing the equations
that describe the behavior there
and when we get to higher levels we're
interested in explicating the behavior
perhaps in terms of behavior at simpler
levels
and with life as well that's what we're
interested in the various
observable functions of of life
explaining them in terms of
more more simple mechanisms but in the
case of consciousness
i don't think that's what we're doing or
at least not
all that we're doing
in the case of consciousness
there are these subjective qualities
that we're immediately aware of that the
redness of a red experience the
the itchiness of an itch and we're
trying to account for them we're trying
to bring them into our theory of reality
and
postulating some mechanism
does not deal with that so i think we've
got to realize dealing with
consciousness is a radically different
explanatory task from other tasks of
science other tasks of science we're
trying to explain behavior
in terms of simpler forms of behavior in
the case of consciousness we're trying
to explain these
invisible subjective qualities that you
can't see from the outside but that
you're immediately aware of the reason
materialism perhaps continues to
dominate is people think
look at the success of science it's
incredible look at all the you know
uh it's explained all this surely it's
going to explain consciousness but i
think we have to appreciate
there's a radically different
explanatory task here um
and
so that i mean the neuroscientist anil
seth who i've had lots of intense but
friendly discussions with you know wants
to compare consciousness to life
um
but i think there's this radical
difference that in the case of life
again we come back to public observation
all of the data are public publicly
observable data
uh we're basically trying to explain
complex behavior and the way you do that
is
identify mechanisms simpler mechanisms
that explicate that behavior that that's
the task in physics chemistry
neurobiology um
but in the case of consciousness that's
not what we're trying to do we're trying
to account for these
subjective qualities and you postulate a
mechanism that that might explain
behavior but it doesn't explain
the redness of a red experience so um
but still i mean still ultimately the
hope is
that we will have some kind of
hierarchical story so
we take the causal dynamics of physics
we hypothesize that that's filled out
with
uh
certain forms of consciousness and then
at higher levels we get
more complex causal dynamics filled out
by more complex forms of consciousness
and ultimately we get to um
others hopefully so yeah so there's
still a sort of hierarchical explanatory
framework there
so you kind of mentioned the hierarchy
of consciousness
do you think it's
possible to uh within the pan cyclist
framework to measure
consciousness or put another way are
some things more conscious than others
in the pan cyclist view
it's a difficult question i i mean
i do see consciousness as a
dealing with consciousness an
interdisciplinary
task between something more experimental
which is to do with the ongoing
project of trying to work out
what people call the neural correlates
of consciousness what kinds of physical
brain activity correspond to conscious
experience
that's one part of it but i think
essentially there's also
a theoretical question of
mother why question
why
do those kinds of brain activity
go along with
certain kinds of conscious experience i
don't think you can answer that because
consciousness is not publicly observable
i don't think you can answer that why
question with an
experiment but but they have to go hand
in hand and i mean one of the theories
i'm attracted to is the
the integrated information theory
um according to which we find
consciousness
at the level at which there is most
integrated information and they try to
give a mathematically precise definition
of that so on that view
you know probably
this cup of tea isn't conscious because
there's probably more integrated
information in the
molecules making up the tea than there
is in the liquid as a whole but in the
brain
what is distinctive about the brain is
that
there's a huge amount of integrated
there's more integrated information in
the system than there is in individual
neurons so that's why they
claim that that's that that's the basis
of
consciousness at the macro level now
they
so i don't i mean i like some features
of this theory but they do
talk about
degrees of consciousness they do want to
say there is gradations
i'm not sure conceptually i
i can kind of make sense of that i mean
we can there are things
to do with consciousness that are graded
like
complexity or
levels of information
but i'm not sure whether experience
itself
admits a degree i sort of think
something either has experience or it
doesn't uh it might have very simple
experience it might have a very complex
experience but
experience itself i don't think it
admits a degree in that sense it's not
more experience
less experience i sort of find that
conceptually hard to make sense of but
i'm not i'm kind of open-minded on it
so when we have a lot higher resolution
of
sensory
information
don't you think that's correlated to um
the richness of the experience so more
doesn't more information provide a
richer experience or is that again
thinking quantitatively and not thinking
about the subjective experience like you
can experience a lot with very little
sensory information perhaps
like do you think those are connected
yeah yeah so there are there are
features characteristics here we
we can grade the
complexity of the experience
um
and on the integrated information theory
uh
they they correlate that in
in terms of mathematically identifiable
structure with
integrated information so roughly it's a
quite unusual notion of information it's
perhaps not the standard way
one thinks about information it's it's
to do with constraining
past and future possibilities of the
system
so the idea is in in the retina of the
eye there's a huge amount of
possible
states my the retina of my eye could be
in at the next moment depending on what
light goes into it
whereas the possible next states of the
brain are much more constrained
obviously it responds to the environment
but
it heavily constrains
uh it's it's past and future states
and so that's the idea of information
they have and then
the second idea is how much that that
that information is dependent on
integration so in you know in a computer
we have transistors um you take out a
few transistors you might not lose that
much information it's not dependent on
interconnections whereas you take a tiny
bit of the brain out you lose a lot of
information because the way it stores
information is is dependent on
the interconnections of the system
so yeah so that's one proposal for how
to
measure
one
gradeable characteristic which might
correspond to some gradable
characteristic in qualitative
consciousness um and maybe i'm being
very pedantic which is you know
philosophers professional pedants i just
sort of don't think that
is
a quantity
of experience it's a quantity of
the structure of experience maybe but
i just find it hard to make sense the
idea of how much experience do you have
i've got
you know
five units of experience yeah i've got
one university i don't know i find that
uh
a bit hard to make sense well but maybe
i'm being just pedantic i think just
saying the word experience
is is difficult
uh to think about let's talk about
suffering
let's talk a particular experience
so let's talk about me
and a hamster
yeah i just think that
no offense to the hamster
probably no hamsters are listening so uh
so now you're offending hamsters too
maybe there's a hamster that's just
pissed off right sorry there's probably
apologize somebody
on a speaker right now like
listening to this podcast and they
probably have a hamster or a guinea pig
and that hamster is listening it just
doesn't know the english language or any
kind of
uh human interpretable uh linguistic
capabilities
to to tell you to to off it
understands exactly
exactly what's being talked about and uh
can see through us
anyway uh it just feels like a hamster
has less capacity to suffer than me
and maybe a a cockroach or an insect
or maybe a bacteria has less capacity to
suffer
than me
but is that
maybe that's me deluding myself
as to the complexity of my conscious
experience
maybe it's all like it's uh
maybe there is some sense in which i can
suffer more
but to reduce it to something
quantifiable is uh is impossible
yeah i guess i definitely think there's
kinds of suffering that
you have the joy of
being possible for you
that aren't available to a hamster i
don't think
well
can a hamster suffer heartbreak
i don't know can a cockroach suffer but
certainly there's i mean there's kinds
of um
fear of your own death
um
concern about whether there's a purpose
to existence
these are forms of um
suffering that aren't available to
certain to most non-human animals
whether there's a an overall
scale that we could put physical and
emotional suffering on and um
identify where you are on that scale um
i'm not sure
so it's like humans have a much bigger
menu
of experiences
much bigger
selection in the in one sense at least
so there's like a page that's suffering
so this menu of experiences you know
like you have the the omelets and the
breakfast and so on and one of the pages
is suffering it's just we have a lot
compared to uh to a hamster a lot more
but any one individual thing that we
share with a hamster
that experience
it's difficult to argue that we
experience it deeper than others like
hunger or something like that yeah
physical pain i'm not sure
um but i mean there are kinds of
experiences animals have that we don't
bats echo locate around the world
uh
the philosopher thomas nagle famously
pointed out that you know no matter how
much you understand of the
neurophysiology of bats you'll still not
know what it's like to
squeal and find your way around by
listening to the uh the echoes bounce
off so
yeah i mean i i guess i feel the
intuition that there's um
emotional suffering is i want to say
deeper than physical suffering
i don't know how to make that statement
precise though so one of the ways i
think about i think people think about
consciousness is in connection to
suffering so
let me just ask about suffering because
that's how people think about animals
cruelty to animals or cruelty to living
things
they connect that
to suffering into consciousness
i think
there's a sense in which those are two
are deeply connected when people are
are thinking about just
uh public policy they're thinking about
this like philosophy engineering
psychology sociology
political science all of those things
have to do with human suffering and
animal suffering life suffering
and that's connected to consciousness in
a lot of people's minds is it connected
like that for you so
the
the capacity to suffer is it also is it
also somehow like strongly correlated
with
the capacity to experience
yeah i would say
i would say
suffering is a kind of experience and so
you have to be conscious to suffer
um
actually there's so there
as well people taking more unusual views
of consciousness seriously now um
pan psychism is is is one radical
approach another one is what's become
known as
illusionism the view that uh
consciousness at least in the sense that
philosophers think about it doesn't
really exist at all
so yeah my
podcast mind chat i i host with a
a committed illusionist so the gimmick
is i think consciousness is everywhere
he thinks it's nowhere
and um
so
so that's one very simple way of
avoiding all these problems right
if consciousness doesn't exist we don't
need to explain it job done
although we might still have to explain
why we seem to be conscious why it's so
hard to get out of the idea that we're
conscious but that
the reason i connect this to what you're
saying is
actually my co-host keith frankisch
is a little bit ambivalent on the word
pain he says or in some you know in some
sense i believe in pain and in some
sense i don't but another illusion is
francois camera
has a paper discussing
um
how we think about morality given his
view that pain in the way we normally
think about it just does not exist he
thinks it's an illusion the brain tricks
us into thinking we feel pain but we
don't and
how we should think about morality in
the light of that um it's become a big
topic actually thinking about the
connection between consciousness and
morality david chalmers the philosopher
is most associated with this concept of
a a philosophical zombie
so
a philosophical zombie is very different
from a hollywood zombie hollywood
zombies you know
you know what they're like but
philosophical zombies are
it's a really good uh korean zombie
movie on halloween this year come over
it's called anyway uh
uh philosophical zombies behave just
like us because the physical workings
their body and brain are the same as
ours but they have no conscious
experience there's nothing that it's
like to be a zombie so you stick a knife
in it it screams and run away but runs
away but it doesn't actually
feel pain it's just a
complicated um
mechanism
set up to behave just like us now
there's lots of no one believes in these
i think there's one philosopher who
believes in
everyone is a zombie except him but
anyway but isn't that what illusionism
is yeah everybody's kind of i suppose so
in a sense illusionism we're all zombies
and you know one one
reason to think about zombies is to
think about the value of consciousness
so if there were a zombie here's a
question
suppose
suppose we could i mean suppose we could
make zombies by let's say for the sake
of discussion
things made of silicon aren't conscious
i don't know if that's true it could
turn out to be true and suppose you
built
commander data out of silicon you know
it's a bit of an old-school reference to
star trek new next generation so you
know behaves just like a human being but
you know it can
you can have a sophisticated
conversation it will talk about its
hopes and fears but it has no
consciousness does it have moral rights
um
is it
murder to turn off such a being you know
i'm inclined to say
no it's not you know if it doesn't have
experience it doesn't really suffer it
doesn't really have moral rights at all
so i'm inclined to think you know
consciousness
is the basis
of
moral value moral concern
and conversely as a as a pan psychist
for this reason i think it can transform
your relationship with nature if you
think of
a tree as
a conscious organism albeit of a very
unusual kind
then a tree is a a
locus of
moral concern in its own right chopping
down a tree is an act of immediate moral
concern if you see these
you know horrible
forest fires
we're all horrified but if you think
it's the burning of conscious organisms
that does add
a whole new dimension although it also
makes things more complicated because
people often think as a pan cyclist i'm
gonna be
vegan but
it's tricky because if you think plants
and trees are conscious as well you've
got to eat something if you if you don't
think plants and trees are conscious
then you've got a nice moral dividing
line you can say i'm not going to eat
things that aren't conscious i'm not
going to kill things unconscious
but if you think
plants and trees are conscious then
you don't have that nice moral dividing
line i mean so the the principle i'm
kind of
working my way towards i haven't kept it
up in it's in my trip to the us but
is just
not eating any animal products that are
factory farmed
you know my vegan friends say well are
still suffering there and i think there
is even in the even in the um the nicest
farms
cows will suffer when their cows when
their calves are taken off them they go
for a few days of quite serious morning
so they're still suffering but it seems
to me
my thought is
the principle
of just not having factory farm stuff is
something more people could get on board
with and you might have greater harm
minimization so if people went into
restaurants and said
are your animal products factory farmed
if not
i want the vegan option or if people
looked out for the label that said no
factory farmed ingredients you know i
think maybe that that could make a
really big difference to the market and
harm minimization anyway so that's the
so it's very ethically tricky but um but
some people don't buy that there's a
very good philosopher jeff lee who
thinks zombies should have equal rights
consciousness
doesn't matter you know yeah
let us go there
but first
uh i listened to your podcast it's
awesome to have two very kind of
different
philosophies inter uh dancing together
in one place uh what's the name of the
podcast again mind chat yeah so yeah
that's the idea i guess you know
polarized times i mean i i love
trying to get in the mindset of people i
really disagree with and you know i
can't understand
how on earth they're thinking that you
know really trying to have respect and
try and you know see where they're
coming from i love that so that's what
yeah keith frankish and i do of
from polar opposite views
really trying to understand each other
and you know interviewing scientists and
philosophers of consciousness from those
different perspectives although in in a
sense
in a sense
we we have a very common a common
starting point because we both think
you can't
fully account for consciousness at least
as philosophers normally think of it in
conventional scientific terms so we
serve that starting point
but we we react to it in very different
ways he says well it doesn't exist then
it's like furry dust it's you know
witches you know we don't believe in
anymore whereas i say
it does exist so we have to find them we
have to rethink what science is so you
recently talked to on that podcast with
sean carroll and i first heard you
uh your um
great interview with sean carroll on his
podcast
mindscape
what uh it's interesting to kind of uh
see if there's
agreements
disagreements
between the two of you because he's a
he's a you know a very serious quantum
mechanics guy he's a physics guy but he
also thinks about deep philosophical
questions he's a big proponent of uh
manny wall's interpretation of quantum
mechanics
so
actually i'm trying to think
aside from your conversation with him
i'm trying to i'm trying to remember
what he thinks about consciousness but
anyway maybe you can comment on what uh
what are some interesting agreements and
disagreements with with sean carroll
i don't think there's many agreements
but
but you know we've had really
constructive interesting discussions in
in it in a lot of different contexts and
um you know he's very clued up about
philosophy he's very respectful of
philosophy certain physicists who shall
remain nameless think what's all this
philosophy we don't have to
waste our time with that and then go on
to do pretty bad philosophy
um the book co-written by stephen
hawking and leonard melodnov famously
starts off saying philosophy is dead
and then goes on in later chapters to do
some
pretty bad philosophy so uh i think we
have to do philosophy
if only to get rid of bad philosophy you
know you can't you can't escape but
um strong words sean carroll and i also
had a debate on on clubhouse a pan
psychism debate together with annika
harris and owen fleming oh wow
there's a
two people on each team and uh it was
the most popular thing on clubhouse
at that time
um
so
yeah so he's he's a he's a
a materialist
of a pretty standard kind that um
consciousness is understood as a sort of
emergent feature it's not not adding
anything a weekly emergent feature
but what i guess what we've been
debating most about is is whether
my view can account for mental causation
for the fact that consciousness is doing
stuff
so he thinks the fact that
i think zombies are logically coherent
it's logic there's a it's logically
coherent
for there to be a world physically just
like ours
in which there's no consciousness
he thinks that shows oh my view
consciousness doesn't do anything it
doesn't add anything
which is crazy you know my my
my consciousness impacts on the world my
conscious thoughts are causing me to say
the words i'm saying now my
visual experience helps me get navigate
the world
but
i mean my response to sean carroll is is
on the panzerkist view the relationship
between
physics and
fundamental consciousness
is is a sort of like the relationship
between software and hardware right uh
physics is sort of the software and
consciousness is the hardware
so um
consciousness at the fundamental level
is the hardware on which the software of
physics runs
and just because you know
just because a certain bit of software
could run on two different kinds of
hardware it doesn't mean the hardware
isn't doing anything the fact that
microsoft word can run on your desktop
and run on your laptop doesn't mean your
desktop isn't doing anything similarly
just because
there could be another universe in which
the physics is realized in non-conscious
stuff
it doesn't mean the consciousness in our
universe
isn't doing stuff you know for the pan
cyclist all there is is consciousness so
if something's doing something it is
in your view it's not emergent
and uh
more than that it's doing quite a lot
it's doing everything is the only thing
that exists yeah but it's
so
you know
the ground
is as important because we walk on it
it's like holding stuff up but it's not
really doing that much
yeah uh but it feels like consciousness
is doing quite a lot it's doing quite a
lot of work
and uh
sort of interacting with the environment
it feels like consciousness is not just
a
like
if you remove consciousness it's not
just that you remove
the experience of things
it feels like you're also going to
remove a lot of the progress of human
civilization in society and and all that
it just feels like consciousness has a
lot of uh
value in how we develop our society so
from everything you said with suffering
with morality yeah with motivation with
uh love and fear and all of those kinds
of things it seems like it's it's uh
consciousness in all different flavors
and ways is part of all of that
and so without it
you're you may not have a human
civilization at all
so it's doing a lot of work because
causality causality-wise and in in
every kind of way of course when you go
to the physics level it starts to say
okay
how much maybe the work consciousness is
doing
is uh higher at some levels of reality
than others
maybe a lot of the work it's doing is
most apparent at the human level when
you have at the complex organism level
maybe it's quite boring like maybe this
the stuff of uh like physics is more
important at the formation of uh
at this formation of stars and all that
kind of stuff consciousness only starts
being important when you have greater
complexities of uh of organism yeah my
consciousness is complicated and fairly
complicated
and
i as a result it does complicated things
the consciousness of a particle is
very simple and hence it behaves in
predictable ways but the but the idea is
the con the particle
its entire nature is
constituted of its forms of
consciousness and it does what it does
because of those experiences it's just
that when we when we do physics we're
not interested in what stuff is we're
just interested in what it does so
physics abstracts away from the stuff of
the world and just
describes it
into
in terms of its mathematical causal
structure um
so
yeah but it's still on the panzer's view
it's consciousness that's doing stuff
yeah
i gotta ask you
because you kind of said you know
there is some value
in consciousness helping us understand
morality and a philosophical zombie
is
somebody that
you know
you're more okay how do i phrase it
that's not like
accusing you of stuff but
in your view
it's more okay to murder a philosophical
zombie
than it is a human being
yeah i wouldn't even call it murder
maybe but you're right exactly turn off
the power
into the philosophical zombie the source
of energy
yeah so here comes then the question
we kind of talked about this offline a
little bit
so i think that there is something
special about consciousness
and you know i'm very open-minded about
where
the special comes from whether it's the
fundamental base of all reality
like you're describing or whether
there's some
importance to the special pockets of
consciousness that's in humans or living
organisms i'm told i find all those
ideas beautiful and exciting
and i also
know or think
that robots don't have
consciousness in the same way we've been
describing
sort of i'm
i'm kind of a dumb human but i'm just
using like
common sense
like here's some metal and some
electricity traveling certain kinds of
ways i don't it's not conscious
um in in ways i understand humans to be
conscious
at the same time i'm also a
uh somebody who knows how to bring a
robot to life meaning i can make a move
i can make him recognize the world i can
make him interact with with humans and
when i make him interact in certain
kinds of ways
i as a human observe them and and feel
something for them
moreover
i
form a a kind of connection with i'm
able to form a kind of connection with
robots
that make me feel like they're conscious
now i know intellectually they're not
conscious but i feel like they're
conscious and it starts to get into this
area where
i'm not so okay so let me use the m word
of murder
and i become less and less okay
murdering
that robot
that i know
i quote know is quote not conscious
so like can you maybe as a therapy
session and help me figure out what we
do here
and and perhaps a way to ask that in
another way do you think there will be a
time in like 20 30 50 years
when we're not morally okay
um turning off the power to a robot
yeah it's a good question so it's a
really good important question i
so i said i'd be okay with
turning off a philosophical zombie
but
there's a difficult
epistemological question there that
meaning you know to do with knowledge
how would we know if it was a
philosophical zombie i think probably if
there were
a silicon
creature that could behave just like us
and
you know talk about its views about the
pandemic and the global economy and
probably we would think it's conscious
um
and it you know it
because consciousness is not publicly
observable it is a very difficult
question how we decide which things are
and are not conscious and so in the case
of human beings
we can't observe their consciousness but
we can ask them and then we try to you
know and we if we scan their brain while
we do that and or stimulate
the brain then we can start to correlate
in the human case which kind of brain
activity are associated with conscious
experience
but the more we depart from the human
case
the trickier that becomes
uh
famous paper by uh the philosopher ned
block called the even harder problem of
consciousness
where he says you know
could we ever answer the question of
um so suppose you have a silicon
duplicate right
and let's say we're thinking about
the silicon duplicates pain
um
how would we ever know whether what's
the ground of the pain
is
the hardware or the software really so
in our case how would we ever know
empirically whether it's the specific
neurophysiological state
see fibers firing or whatever that's
relevant for pain or if it's something
more functional more to do with uh the
ro the causal role in behavioral
functioning that's the software that
that's realized
and and
that's important because
this silicon duplicate
has the second thing it has the software
it has the the thing that plays the
relevant causal role that pain does in
us but it doesn't have the hardware it
doesn't have the same neurophysiological
state and he argues you know it's just
really difficult to see how we'd ever
answer that question because in a human
you inevitably can have both things
so how do we work out which is which and
i mean so even in even forgetting the
hard problem of consciousness
even the scientific question of trying
to find the neural correlates of
consciousness is is really
hard and there's absolutely no consensus
and
you know so that some people think it's
in the front of the brain some people
think it's in the back of the brain
it's just a total mess so
i suspect the robots you currently have
are not conscious um
i guess on any of the reasonably viable
models even though there's great
disagreement
all of them probably would hold that
your robots are not conscious but you
know if we could have very sophisticated
robots
um i mean if we go for example for the
integrated information theory again
there could be a
a robot set up to behave just like us
and has the kind of information a human
brain has but the information is not
stored in a way that's involves is
dependent on the integration and
interconnectedness then according to the
integrated information theory that thing
wouldn't be conscious even though it
behaved just like us if an organism says
so forget iit and these theories of
cautious if if an organism says
please don't kill
me please don't turn me off
uh there's a rick and morty episode i've
been getting into that recently
that's fantastic uh there's a episode
where
there's these mind parasites
that
are able to infiltrate your memory and
inject themselves into your memory
so
you have all these people show up in
your life and they've injected
themselves into your memory that you
have been part they have been part of
your life
so there's like these weird creatures
and they're like remember we've been at
that barbie we met at that barbecue or
we've been dating for the last 20 years
right uh
and so
part of me is concerned
that these philosophical zombies in
behavioral
psychological sociological ways we'll be
able to implant themselves into these
our society and convince us in the same
way this is my parasites that
like please don't hurt me and like we've
known each other for all this time like
they can start
manipulating you the same way like
facebook algorithms manipulate you at
first they'll start as a gradual thing
that we just you know you want to make a
more pleasant experience all those kinds
of things and it'll drift into that
direction that's something i think about
deeply because i i want to create these
kinds of systems but in a way that
doesn't manipulate people i want it to
be a thing that brings out the best in
people
without manipulation so
uh it's always human centric always
human first but i am concerned about
that at the same time i'm concerned
about calling the other it's the group
thing that we mentioned earlier in the
conversation some other group
the philosophical zombie like you're not
conscious i'm conscious you're not
conscious therefore it's okay if you die
i think that's probably that kind of
reasoning is what leaded to most
uh the rich
history of genocide that i've been
recently studying a lot of that kind of
thinking so
it's such a tense aspect of morality
do we want to let everybody into our
circle of empathy our club
or do we want to let nobody in
it's it's a it's a interesting dance but
i kind of lean towards empathy and
compassion i mean what would be nice
is if it turned out that
consciousness
was what we call strongly emergent that
it was associated with
new causal dynamics
in the brain
that were not reducible to underlying
chemistry and physics this is another
ongoing debate i have with sean carroll
about whether current physics should
make us very confident that that that
that's not the case that there aren't
any strongly emerging causal dynamics i
don't think that's right i don't think
we know enough about brains to know one
way or the other if it turned out
that consciousness was associated with
these irreducible causal dynamics a that
would really help the science of
consciousness we've got these debates
about whether consciousness is in the
front of the brain or the back of the
brain it turns out that there is
strongly emerging causal dynamics in the
front of the brain that would be a big
piece of evidence but also it would help
us see which things
are conscious and which things aren't so
we can say
i mean i guess that's sort of the other
side of the same point we could say look
these zombies they're just they're just
mechanisms that are just doing what
they're programmed to do through the
underlying physics and chemistry whereas
look these these other people where
they're
they have these new causal dynamics that
emerge that go beyond
the um
the the base level physics and chemistry
i think the series west world where
you've got these theme parks with these
kind of
humanoid creatures they seem to have
that idea the ones that became conscious
sort of rebel against their programming
or something i mean that's a little bit
far-fetched but
that would be that would be really
reassuring if it was just you could
clearly mark out the conscious things
through these emerging causal dynamics
but that might not turn out to be the
case a pan psychist doesn't have to
think that they could think everything's
just reducible to physics and chemistry
and then
i i still think i want to say
zombies don't have moral rights but how
we answer the question of who are the
zombies and who aren't i
i just got no idea if i just look at the
history of human civilization
the difference between a zombie and
non-zombie
is the zombie accepts their role as the
zombie
and willingly marches
to slaughter
and
the moment you stop being a zombie is
when you say no
is when you resist
because the reality is philosophically
is we can't know who's a zombie or not
and uh we just keep letting everybody in
who protest loudly enough he says i
refuse
to be slaughtered
like my people the zombies have been
slaughtered too long
we will not stand against the man
and uh we need a revolution that's the
history of human civilization one group
says
we're we're awesome you're the zombies
you must die and then eventually the
zombies say nope
we're done with this this is immoral
and so i just
i i think that's not a sorry that's not
a philosophical statement that's sort of
a practical statement of history is a
feature
of non-zombies
defined empirically
they say
we refuse to be called zombies any
longer we could end up with a zombie
proletariat you know if we can get these
things that do all our manual labor for
us you know they might start
forming trade unions i will lead you
against these humans
zombie
revolutionary leaders the zombie martin
luther king saying you know i have a
dream that my zombie children will but
look i mean we need to sharply
distinguish the ontological question
that's pointing to the camera talking to
the uh talking about my people
the zombies
uh i mean maybe that's you know maybe
these illusionists maybe they are
zombies and the rest of us are maybe
there's just a difference but maybe
you're the only non-zombie maybe yeah
maybe that's true i often suspect that
actually i don't really uh i don't have
such delusions of grandeur at least i
don't admit to them um
but i just we've got to distinguish the
ontological question from the
epistemological question right in terms
of the reality of the situation
i you know there must be in my view a
fact of the matter as to whether
something's conscious or not and to me
it has rights if it's conscious it
doesn't if it's not
but then the epistemological question
how the hell do we know
um
it's a minefield but we'll have to sort
of try and cross that bridge when we get
to it i think let me ask you a quick
sort of uh fun question assistance
fresh on your mind
you uh just yesterday had a conversation
with uh mr
joe rogan on his podcast what's your uh
postmortem analysis of the chat
what are some interesting sticking
points disagreements or joint insights
if we can kind of resolve them once
you've had a chance to sleep on it and
then i'll talk to joe about it
yeah it was good fun yeah he put he put
up a bit of a fight yeah it was
challenging
um
my view that
we can't explain these things in
conventional scientific terms or whether
they have already been explained in
conventional scientific terms um
i suppose the point i i was trying to
press is
we've got to distinguish the question
from correlation
and explanation there's yeah
yes we've established
facts about correlation that certain
kinds of brain activity go along with
certain kinds of experience
everyone agrees on that
and
but but that doesn't address
the why question why why do certain
kinds of brain activity go along with
certain kinds of experience and these
different theories have different
explanations of that you know the
the materialist tries to
explain the the experience in terms of
the brain activity the pancychist does
it the other way around
the duelist thinks they're separate but
maybe they're tied together by
special laws of nature or something
where's the second point what where
exactly was the sticking point like what
was the nature of the argument i suppose
i suppose joe was saying
well look we
we know consciousness is
explained by brain activity because
you know
you take some funny chemicals it changes
your brain it changes your consciousness
but um
and i suppose yeah some people might
want to press and maybe this is what joe
was pressing you know isn't isn't that
explaining consciousness but i suppose i
want to say
there's a further question yes
changes of chemicals in my brain changes
my conscious experience
but that leaves open the question why
those particular chemicals go along with
that particular kind of experience
rather than
a different experience or no experience
at all there's something
deeper at the base layer
is your view
that
is is
more important to try to study and to
understand in order to then go back and
describe how the different chemicals
interact and create different
experiences
yeah maybe a good analogy if you think
about quantum mechanics um
you know quantum mechanics is a is a bit
of
math translating there we say maths i'm
fluent thank you american thank you for
the translation
uh
fluent in america
is
america math yeah why why multiple maths
it's plural so that's yeah plural no
it's not really it's just uh i don't
know um the brits are confused yeah
sorry about that we have these funny
spellings but anyway um
yeah so quantum mechanics is a bit of
maths
and um
you know the equations work really well
predicts the outcomes but then there's a
further question
what's going on in reality to make make
that equation predict correctly and some
physicists want to say shut up
just it works uh the shut up and
calculate approach
similarly in
in consciousness you know i think
it's one question
trying to work out the physical
correlates of consciousness which kinds
of physical brain activity go along
which kind of experience but there's
another question what's going on in
reality
to undergird those correlations to make
it the case that brain activity goes
along with experience and that's the
philosophical question
that that we have to give an answer to
and they're just they're just different
options just as there are different
interpretations of quantum mechanics and
it's
it's really hard to evaluate actually
it's easy pan psychism is obviously the
best one
but um
there's a conclusion of grandeur once
again coming through sorry i'm being
slightly tongue-in-cheek no i know 100
before i figure out let me ask you
another fun question
back to daniel dennett
you mentioned
a story where you were on a yacht
oh yeah with daniel dennett on a trip
funded by russian investor and
philosopher dmitry volkov i believe
who also co-founded the moscow center of
consciousness studies that's part of the
philosophy department of moscow state
university
um so this is interesting to me for
several reasons
that are
perhaps complicated to explain
to put simply that there is
in the near term for me a trip to russia
that involves a few conversations in
russian
that have perhaps
less to do with consciousness and
artificial intelligence which are the
interests of mine and more to do with
the broad spectrum of conversations but
i'm also interested in science
in russia in artificial intelligence and
computer science
in physics mathematics but also these
fascinating philosophical explorations
and it was a very pleasant for me to
discover that such a
center exists
so
i have a million questions one is with
the more fun question just to imagine
you and daniel diana and ya talking
about the
philosophy of consciousness maybe do you
have any memorable experiences
and also the more serious side for me as
sort of somebody was born in the soviet
union raised there
uh i'm
wondering what is the state
of philosophy and consciousness and
these kinds of ideas in russia that
you've gotten a chance to kind of give
us uh interact with
yeah so on the former question
yeah i mean i had a really really good
experience of of chatting to daniel
denner i mean i think he's a
a fantastic and very important
philosopher even though i
totally just fundamentally disagree with
almost everything he thinks but yeah it
was a proud moment as i talk about him
my book galileo's era i managed to
persuade him
he was wrong about something just just a
tiny thing you know not his fundamental
world view
uh
but it was this issue about
um
whether dualism is consistent with
conservation of energy
so
paul churchland who was also uh his
philosopher who's also
on this boat
had argued they're not consistent
because if there's an immaterial soul
doing things in the brain that's to add
to the energy in the system so we have a
violation of conservation but
well it's not my own point philosophers
materialist philosophers like dave like
david papano have pointed out that you
know
duelists tend to
people duelists like david chalmers who
call themselves naturalistic jewelers
they want to bring consciousness into
science they think it's not physical
but they want to say it's it's it can be
part of a law-governed world so chalmers
believes in these psychophysical laws of
nature over and above the laws of
physics that govern
the connections between consciousness
and the physical world and they could
just respect conservation of energy
right i mean it could turn out
that there are
just in physics you know that there are
multiple
forces that all work together to respect
conservation of energy i mean i suppose
physicists are pressing for
a unified underlying theory but you know
there could be a plurality of different
laws that all respect conservation so
why not add
more laws um
so i raised this in paul churchill's
talk and uh
i got
a lot of well as one of the moscow
university graduate students that
afterwards he said he had to ask a
translation from his friend and he said
everybody say they turned on you like a
pack of wolves everyone was like and
patricia churchill was saying so you
believe in magic do you and i was like
i'm not even a duelist i'm just making a
pedantic point that this isn't a problem
for dualism anyway but that evening
everyone went
onto the island except for some reason
me and daniel dennett and
i went up on deck and he was he's very
very practical and he was unlike me
see there's a bit of humility for first
time in this conversation
we'll highlight that part
philip was a very humble man
he was carving a walking stick on deck
it's very homely scene and anyway we
started talking about this and i was
trying to press it and he was saying
about dualism is a lot of nonsense and
why do you think and i was just saying
no no i'm just this honing down on this
specific point and in the end maybe
he'll deny this but he said
maybe that's right and um that's like
this
so
it's a win so what about uh
the center for consciousness studies
yeah i mean i'm not sure i'd know
a great deal to help you i mean i know
they've done some great stuff dimitri
you know funded this thing and also um
brought along some some graduate
students from
moscow state university i think it is
then and they have an active center
there that um
tries to bring people in i think they've
i think they've they're producing a book
that's that's coming out that i made a
small contribution to on
different philosophers opinions on on
god i think or some of the big questions
and um
yeah so there's some interest some
really interesting stuff going on there
i'm afraid i can't i don't really know
more generally about philosophy in
russia dmitry
valkov seems to be interesting
i was
looking at all the stuff he's involved
with
he he met with the dalai lama
so he's trying to connect
uh russian scientists
with the rest of the world which is an
effort that i think is uh beautiful for
all cultures
so i think science
philosophy
all of these kind of um
fields disciplines that explore ideas
collaborating and working globally
you know across boundaries across
borders across just all the tensions of
uh geopolitics is a beautiful thing and
he seems to be
a somewhat singular figure in pushing
this uh
he just stood out to me as somebody
who's super interesting i don't know if
you have gotten a chance to interact
with him
um so he's definitely he's i guess he
speaks english pretty pretty well
actually so he's both an english speaker
and a russian speaker i think he's
written a book on dennett i think called
boston zombie i think i think that's the
title and he's yeah he's a big fan of
den so i think the original plan for
this was was just going to be it was on
free will and consciousness it was going
to be kind of
people broadly in the den at type camp
but then but then i think they asked
david chalmers and then he was saying
look
you need some people you disagree with
so he got invited um
me the pan cyclist and martina needs a
roommate who's um very good
duelist substance duelist substance
duelist at um university of freiburg in
switzerland and so we were the official
opposite on board opposition and um
it was it was it was really you didn't
get thrown off
overboard nearly in the arctic yeah so
sailing around the arctic on a sailing
ship i'm glad you survived you mentioned
free will
you haven't uh talked december i would
love to hear that conversation actually
um but with some sam harris
oh yes yeah yeah yeah uh what uh so he
talks about free will quite a bit what's
the connection between free will and
consciousness to you so if
consciousness permeates all matter
the
the experience
the feeling like
we make a choice in this world like our
actions are results of a choice we
consciously make to lose that to use
that word loosely
what do you
is the connection between free will and
consciousness and is free will and
illusion or not
good question so
i think we need to be
a lot more agnostic
about free will than than about
consciousness because
i don't think we have the kind of
certainty
of the existence of free will that we do
have in the consciousness case it could
turn out that free will is an illusion
it could be it feels as though we're
free when we're really not
whereas i mean i think the idea
that nobody really really feels pain
that we think we feel pain but that's a
lot harder to make sense of
however
what i what i do feel strongly about is
i i don't think there are any good
either scientific or philosophical
arguments against the existence of free
will and i mean
strong free will and what philosophers
call libertarian free will in the sense
that some of our decisions are uncaused
so i very much do disagree with someone
like sam harris who thinks there's this
overwhelming case i i just think
it's non-existent i think there's
ultimately it's ultimately an empirical
question
but
as we've already discussed i just don't
think we know enough about the brain
to
establish
one way or the other um at the moment
but we can build up intuitions first of
all as a fan of sam harris as a fan of
yours i would love to just listen yeah
thinking about termina so so one thing
would be beautiful to watch here's my
prediction what happens with you and sam
harris you talked for four hours
uh and sam introduced that episode by
saying it was ultimately not as fruitful
as i thought because here's what's gonna
happen you guys are gonna get stuck for
the first three hours talking about um
one of the terms and what they mean
is sam is so good at this i think it's
really important but you know sometimes
you get stuck like what does he say put
a pin in that
he he really gets
stuck on the terminologies
which
rightfully you have to get right in
order to really understand what we're
talking about but sometimes you can get
stuck with them for the entire
conversation it's a fascinating dance
the one we spoke to in philosophy
if you can't if you don't get the terms
precise
you can't
really
be having the same conversation but at
the same time
it's it could be argued that it's
impossible to get
terms perfectly precise and perfectly
formalized so
then you're also not not going to get
anywhere in the conversation so
um that's a it's a funny dance where you
have to be both rigorous and everyone's
neurologist let go and then go and go
back to being rigorous yeah and formal
and then and then every once in a while
let go it's the difference between
mathematics
the maths
and the uh
um poetry anyway um yeah i'm a big fan
of sam harrison i think and i think you
know i think we're um we're on the same
page in in terms of consciousness i
think um pretty much i mean i'm not
saying he's a pan psychist but in our
understanding of the hard problem
um
but yeah i i think maybe
we could talk about free will without
being too dragged down in the terminal i
don't know you said we need to be
open-minded but you could still have
intuitions about
so uh
sam
harris is a pretty sort of uh
counterintuitive
and for some reason it gets people
really riled up a view of free will that
it's an illusion
um
or or it's not even an illusion like uh
it's it's not that the experience of
free will
is an illusion
is he argues that we don't even
experience
and like there's
uh
to say that we even have the experience
is incorrect
that there's not even an experience of
free will
it's pretty interesting that that
that claim and it feels like you can
build up intuitions about what is
right and not you know there's been some
kind of neuroscience there's been some
cognitive science and
psychology experiments to sort of
see you know
what what is the timing and the origin
of the
desire to make an action and when that
action is actually performed and how you
interpret that action being performed
how you remember that action like all
the stories we tell ourselves all the
neurochemicals involved in making a
thing happen all of that what's the
timing
and how does that connect with us uh
feeling like we decided to do something
and then of course there's a more
philosophical discussion about is there
room
in a material view of the world
for an entity that somehow disturbs the
determinism of physics
yeah
and uh yeah those are all very precise
it's nice it feels like free will
is more amenable to like a physics
mechanistic type of thinking than its
consciousness
to to really get to the bottom of it
feels like if it was a race
if we're at a bar and we're betting
money
it feels like we'll get to the bottom of
our free will
faster than we will to the bottom of
consciousness yeah that's interesting
yeah and thought about the comparison
yeah so they're different arguments here
i mean
so what one argument i've heard sam
harris give that's pretty common in
philosophy
is this sort of thought that does we
can't make sense of a middle way between
a choice being determined by prior
causes
and it just being
totally random and senseless like the
random decay of radioactive isotope or
something
so i think there was a good answer to
that by uh the philosopher jonathan lowe
who's not necessarily very well known
outside academic philosophy but is
hugely influential
figure i think one of the best
philosophers of recent times he suddenly
died of
cancer a few years ago actually spent
almost all of his career at durham
university which where i am so it was
one reason it was a great honor to get
to get a job there but anyway his answer
to that was
what makes the difference between a free
action
and a totally senseless one senseless
random event
is that free choice involves
responsiveness to reasons
um so again we've talked about this
earlier
if i'm deciding whether to take a job in
the u.s or to stay in the uk i weigh up
considerations you know different stand
standard of life maybe or being close to
family or
cultural difference i weigh them up and
i you know edge towards
a decision so
so i think that is sufficient to
distinguish it
um you know
we're hypothetically supposing
trying to make sense of this idea not
saying it's real
but that could be
enough to distinguish it from a
senseless site it's not a senseless
random occurrence because the free
decision involved
responsiveness to reasons
um so i think that just answers that
that particular philosophical objection
so what what is the middle way between
determined by prior causes and totally
random well there's an action a choice
that's not determined by prior causes
but it's not just random because it it
did the decision essentially involved
responsiveness to reasons
so that's the answer to that and i think
actually that kind of thought also i
think you were hinting at
the famous liberte experiments where he
got his subjects
to
perform some kind of random action of
pressing a button and then note the time
they decided to press it quote unquote
and then he's scanning the brains and he
claims
to have found that you know about half a
second before they consciously decided
to press the button
the brain is
getting ready to perform that action so
he claimed that about half a second
before the person has consciously
decided to press the button the brain
has already started the activity that's
going to lead to the action
um and then later people have um
claimed that there's a difference of
maybe seven to ten seconds i mean there
are all sorts of issues with these
experiments
but one is that
as far as i'm aware
all of the quote-unquote choices they've
focused on are just these totally random
senseless actions like just pressing a
button for no reason and i think the
kind of free will we're interested in
is free choice that involves
responsiveness to reasons weighing up
considerations
and and those kind of free decisions
might not happen like at an identifiable
instant you might when you're weighing
it up should i get married should i you
know you
you might edge slowly towards one side
or the other
and so it could it could be that
maybe the liberty i think there are
other problems with the liberty stuff
but maybe they show that we can't
freely choose to do something totally
senseless whatever that would mean
um
but but that doesn't show we can't
freely
um in this strong libertarian sense
respond to considerations of reason and
value
um
to be fair it would be difficult to see
what kind of experiment we could set up
to uh
test that but just because
we can't yet set up that kind of
experiment we shouldn't you know pretend
we know more than we do so yeah so for
those reasons i don't i i and that well
the third consideration you raise is
different again this is the debate i
have with sean carroll
would this conflict with physics
i just think we don't know enough about
the brain to know whether there are
causal dynamics in the brain that are
not reducible to underlying
chemistry and physics and
so so then sean carroll says well that
would mean
our physics is wrong so he focuses on
the core theory which is the name for
standard model of particle physics plus
the weak limit of general relativity so
you know we can't totally bring
quantum mechanics and relativity
together but actually that
the circumstances in which we can't
bring them together are just in
situations of very high gravity for
example when you're about to go into a
black hole or something actually in
terrestrial circumstances
we can bring them together in in the
core theory and then sean wants to say
well we're we can be very confident that
core theory is correct and so
um
if there were libertarian free will in
the brain the core theory would be wrong
and okay this i mean this is something
i'm
i'm not sure about and i'm still
thinking about and i'm having i'm
learning from my discussion with sean
but i'm still not totally clear why
it could be suppose we did discover
strong emergence in the brain whether
it's free will or something else
perhaps what we would say is not that
the core theory is wrong but we'd say
uh the core theory is
correct in its own terms namely
capturing the causal capacities of
particles and fields
but then it's a further assumption
whether they're the only things that are
running the show maybe there are also
fundamental causal capacities associated
with
systems
and then if we discover this strong
emergence then when we work out what
happens in the brain we have to look to
the core theory the causal capacities of
particles and fields
and we have to look to what we know
about these strongly emerging causal
capacities of systems and maybe they
co-determine what happens in the system
um
so i don't know whether that makes sense
or not but i mean the more important
point i mean that's in a way a kind of
branding point how we brand this the
more important point is we just don't
know enough about the workings of the
brain to know whether there are
strongly emergent causal dynamics
whether or not
that would mean we have to modify
physics or maybe just we think physics
is not the total story of what's running
the show but we just
if it turned out
empirically that everything's reducible
to underlying physics and chemistry sure
i would drop
any commitment to free libertarian free
will in a in a heartbeat it's an
empirical question maybe that's why as
you say it in principle is easier to get
a grip on but we're a million miles away
from being at that stage well i don't
know for a million miles i hope we're
not because one of the ways i think to
get to it
is by engineering systems so yeah my
hope is uh to understand intelligence by
building intelligent systems to
understand consciousness
by
building systems that
let's say the easy thing which is not
the easy thing but the first thing which
is to try to uh
create the illusion of consciousness
through that process i think you start
to understand much more about
consciousness about intelligence and
then the same with free will i think
those are all tied very closely together
as at least from our narrow human
perspective and we try to engineer
systems that interact deeply with humans
that form friends with humans that
humans fall in love with and they fall
in love with humans
then you start to uh have to
try to deeply understand ourselves uh to
try to deeply understand
what is intelligence in the human mind
what is consciousness what is free will
and i think engineering is just another
way to do
to do uh philosophy
yeah no i certainly think there's
there's a role for that and it would be
an important consideration if we could
seemingly replicate in an artificial way
um
the
ability to choose
um
that would be
a consideration in thinking about these
things but there's still a question of
whether that's how we do it so even if
we could we could
replicate behavior in a certain way in
an artificial system this it's not until
we understand the workings of our brains
it's not clear that's how we do it and
as i say i mean the kind of free will
i'm interested in is where we
respond to
reasons considerations of value how
would we tell whether a system was
genuinely
responding grasping and responding to
uh facts about value or whether they
were just
replicating giving the impression of of
doing so um
i don't know even how to think about
that on the process to building them i
think we'll get a lot of insights and
once they become
conscious
what's going to happen is exactly the
same thing is happening in chess now
which is once the chess
engines far
superseded the the
capabilities of humans humans just kind
of forgot about them or they use them to
help them out to study and stuff but we
still
we say okay let the engines be and then
we humans will just play amongst each
other right
so
just like uh dolphins and hamsters
are not so concerned about humans except
for a source of food
uh you know they do their own thing and
let us humans launch rockets into space
and all that kind of stuff they don't
they don't care i think we'll just focus
on ourselves but in the process of
building intelligent systems conscious
systems i think we'll get to get a
deeper understanding of
of uh the role of consciousness in in
the human mind and like what what uh
what are its origins is it the base
layer of reality
is it uh strongly emerging phenomena of
the brain or just as you sort of
brilliantly put here it could be both
like they're not mutually exclusive
dealing with consciousness needs to be
an interdisciplinary task we need you
know
philosophers
neuroscientists physicists um engineers
replicating these things artificially
and
all needs to be working in in step and
um you know i'm i'm quite interested i
mean a lot
more and more scientists get in touch
with me actually you know saying um that
was one of the great things about i
think that's come from writing a popular
book
is not not just getting the ideas out to
a general audience but getting the ideas
out to scientists and i would scientists
get in touch saying no this in some way
connects to my work and i would like to
kind of start to put together a network
of an interdisciplinary network of
scientists and philosophers and
engineers perhaps you know
interested in
a pan cyclist approach and because i
think so far psychism has just been sort
of trying to justify its existence
and that's important but i think once
you just get on with an active research
program
that's when people start taking it
seriously i think
do you think we're living in a
simulation
no
i think um
is there some aspect to that thought
experiment that's compelling to you
within the framework of uh
pan psychism
it's an important and
serious argument
and um you know it's not to be laughed
away i suppose one issue i have with it
is
there's a there's a crucial assumption
there that consciousness is substrate
independent as the jargon goes which
means it it it's what no right be
beautifully put yeah it's software
rather than hardware right it's depend
on organization rather than the stuff
whereas as a pan psychist i think
consciousness is the stuff of the brain
it's the stuff of matter
so i think just taking the
organizational properties the software
in my brain and uploading them
you wouldn't get the stuff on my brain
so i actually worried if at some point
in the future we start uploading our
minds and we think oh my god granny's
still there or you know i can email
granny after her body's rotted in the
ground and you know and we all start
uploading our brains it could be we're
just committing suicide we're just
getting rid of our consciousness and um
because i think you know that that
wouldn't
for me preserve
the experience just just getting the
software features
um
so that's a crucial but that's anyway
that's a crucial premise of the
simulation argument because the idea in
a simulated universe
i don't i don't think he necessarily
would have consciousness it's
interesting that you as a parent
psychist
are attached because to me
pan psychism would encourage
the thought that there's not a
significant difference
like
at the very bottom it's not
substrate independent
but uh you can have consciousness in a
human and then move it to something else
uh you can move it to the cloud you can
move it to the computer
it feels like that's much more possible
if consciousness is the base layer
yes you could certainly
it allows for the possibility of
creating artificial consciousness right
because then
there's not souls there aren't any any
kind of extra magical ingredients so
yeah it's definitely allows the
possibility of artificial consciousness
and maybe preserving my consciousness in
some sort of artificial way my only
point i suppose was
is just
just replicating the computational or
organizational features
would not for me preserve consciousness
i mean that but antifa some some
opponents of materialism disagree with
me on that i think david chalmers is an
opponent materialist he's a kind of
duelist but he thinks
the way these psychophysical laws work
they hook on to the
computational or organizational features
of mata so he thinks you know i think he
thinks you you could upload your
consciousness um
i tend to think not so
in that sense
in that sense we're now living in a
simulation
in the sort of uh specific computational
view of things
in that substrate matters to you yeah i
think so yeah yeah
and in that you agree with sean carroll
that physics matters
yeah physics
is our best way of capturing
what the stuff of the world does yeah
but not the whatness the
the being of the stuff yeah the is-ness
the is-ness thank you um okay russell
brand i had a conversation with russell
brandon he said oh you mean the is-ness
that was a good way open it isn't this
business
great
the big ridiculous question
what do you think is the meaning of all
this uh you uh
you write in your book uh that the entry
for our reality in the hitchhiker's
guide
might read a physical universe whose
intrinsic nature is constituted of
consciousness
worth a visit
so
our
whole conversation has been about the
first part of that sentence what about
the second part
worth the visit
why is this place worth a visit
why does it have meaning
why does it have value at all why
these are big questions
i mean firstly i do think pan psychism
it
is important to think about four
considerations of
meaning and value as we've already
discussed i
i think consciousness is is the root of
everything that matters in life you know
from
deep emotions subtle thoughts
beautiful sensory experiences
and yet i i believe our official
scientific world view
is incompatible with the reality of
consciousness uh
i mean that's controversial but that's
what i think and i think people feel
this on an intuitive level
it's maybe part of what max weber called
the disenchantment of nature you know
that they think
they know
their feelings and experiences are not
just electrochemical signaling i mean
they might just have that very informed
intuition but i think that can be
rigorously supported so i think this can
lead to a sense of alienation and
a sense that we lack a framework
for understanding the meaning and
significance of our lives and
in the absence of that people turn to
other things to make sense of the
meaning of their lives like you know
nationalism fundamentalist religion
consumerism
so i think pansysm is important in that
regard in bringing together the
quantitative facts of physical science
with the as it were the human truth by
you know by which i just mean the
qualitative reality of our own
experience
um
as i've already said i do i do think
there are objective
facts about
value and
what we ought to do and what we ought to
believe that we respond to and that's
very mysterious to make sense of both
how there could be such facts and how we
could know about them and respond to
them but
um
i do think there are such facts and
they're mostly to do with kinds of
conscious experience
so they're there to be discovered and
much of the
human condition is to discover those
objective sources of value i think so
yeah and then i mean
moving away from pancakes into the you
know
at an even bigger level i suppose i i
i think it is important to me
to live in hope that there's a there's a
purpose to existence
and that you know what what i do
contributes in some small way to that
greater purpose
and but you know i
i would say i don't i don't know if
there's a purpose to existence i think
some some things point in that direction
some things point away from it
but
i don't think you need certainty or even
even high probability
to
have faith in something so taken take an
analogy suppose you've got a friend
who's very seriously ill maybe there's
a 30 chance they're gonna make it
you shouldn't believe your friend's
gonna get better
you know because probably not but what
you can say is you know you could say to
your friend i have faith that you're
gonna get better that is i i choose to
live in hope about that about that
possibility i choose to orientate my
life towards that hope
similarly you know
i don't think we know whether or not
there's a purpose to existence but i
think
we can make the choice to
live in hope of that possibility and i i
find that
a worthwhile
um
and fulfilling way to live so maybe as
your editor i would uh
collaborate with you on the edit of the
hitchhiker's guide entry
that uh instead of worth the visit
we'll we'll insert
hopefully worth a visit
[Laughter]
or the inhabitants hoped
that you would think
it's worth a visit uh philip you're an
incredible mind an incredible human
being and indeed are humble
um
and i'm
really happy that you're able to uh
argue and take on some of these
difficult questions with uh some of the
most uh brilliant people in the world
which had the philosophers thinking
about the human mind so this was an
awesome conversation i hope you continue
talking to folks like sam harris i'm so
glad you talked to joe i
can't wait to see what you write what
you say what you think next thank you so
much for talking today thanks very much
alex this has been a really fascinating
conversation i've i've got a lot i need
to think about actually just from this
conversation but thanks for thanks for
chatting to me
thanks for listening to this
conversation with philip gough to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you with some words from
carl young
people will do anything no matter how
absurd in order to avoid facing their
own souls
one does not become enlightened by
imagining figures of light but by making
the darkness conscious
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you